The joe rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
Damn,
I forgot to tweet that I was doing this.
Should I tweet it?
Tweet it while I'm talking about it while we're talking about the fleshlight.
What's this?
What we do?
We'll have an extended little conversation about the flashlight while I tweak
this.
Here we go.
Jokes.
You have a butthole on here that that's been used as a prop since we started
getting sponsored by the flashlight.
And so many comics fingers are so dirty and nasty.
Now the Butthole,
it looks like a white really bad.
Yeah,
it does look like a dirty butthole and it slept a weird,
like sort of like a really,
uh,
like not a black person,
but like a really dark islander.
Yeah.
When they have you ever see like,
like,
like girls from like the Filipino Hawaiian girls asshole.
They have,
there's a certain darkness to the vagina area.
Yeah.
What's that all about?
It's just,
you know,
just like some people's butts are normal color,
some people just are purple.
But do you think there's some evolutionary reason to have your,
uh,
your,
your butthole in your vagina?
Lips darker.
Yeah,
because there's not supposed to fuck it.
You know that there's a dangerous bitches are better.
The dark,
the sweeter the juice.
Right,
right.
Isn't that what the theory behind that shit is always fear of a white planet?
What the fuck are we talking about?
Go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the fleshlight and you can get 15% off the number one sex
toy and they have like Zombie flashlights.
Now case you can fuck a mouth of a vampire.
I think.
Oh No,
it's even worse now.
Now it looks like there's like,
it's been damaged in a car accident and it's just like,
it looks like or feels like it's decaying.
Oh,
what the fuck is wrong with people?
Is that like a novelty thing?
I think is,
yeah,
the holidays and shit.
And you know,
there's a lot of horror fans.
Yeah.
Gas,
but to fuck it,
it's one thing.
Maybe it's a novelty one.
Maybe it's like a car that you don't drive because it's a special edition
corvette or some shit.
So just put it in your garage and hope it's an investment.
We're also brought to you by on it,
O,
n n I t.com.
Makers of Alpha brain.
Alpha brain is a cognitive,
some enhancing.
I always fuck this up.
It's just the pills are supposed to make you smart.
And I see I don't have anything planned out.
We never like sat down and said,
well this is what we'll say about Alpha brain.
So I say,
oh,
it's a cognitive enhancing something or another.
It's fucking real good for making you fuck man.
Want to feel pretty clear when I'm on it.
But how ironic that when you start talking about it this,
this,
for some reason this subject makes people mad.
This bringing up this Alpha brain thing.
So I want to say this,
please don't buy it please.
I want,
this is what I want you to do.
I want you to try find what the ingredients are and Alpha brain,
look it up online and on a.com it's available.
Take the exact ingredients of some bulk stuff that you can buy for much cheaper
than what we did when we put all this together in like sort of a one-stops
shopping sort of a situation.
Go buy that stuff,
please,
please buy it and just try it.
And I know people have positive results.
I've talked to people with it.
Some people don't.
Some people,
and I don't know whether that's a subjective thing,
I don't know whether or not they,
they,
they can't differentiate between a good and a bad day,
whether it just doesn't work on them.
Where everybody's biologically different.
I mean some people can't eat peanuts.
One peanut no fucking die.
Everyone's system is different.
For me,
the shit works.
I'm not lying to you.
Please stop saying I am.
Stop sending me mean tweets.
It's annoying.
You don't have to buy it.
I'm not forcing you to.
But to tell me that I'm not experiencing positive results from it.
And then all these other people that are taking it in and talking to me about
all the great results.
Just to say that we're not selling,
saying,
telling the truth is just insulting and it's stupid and it doesn't make sense.
You fuckhead you don't know what I'm feeling.
And by the way,
it's not the placebo effect because you could have fucking incredible vivid
dreams and their vivid dreams to me.
I don't remember ever having dreams like this for,
I started taking this shit.
I don't even know if it's more vivid.
I think you just,
it like,
I remember it more like you usually wake up and you forget it.
Now I can remember true.
I know.
Yeah.
How would I know if I don't remember him?
Whether or not there were vivid.
Yeah,
but that to me is like stats,
some fucking tangible proof,
man.
And even if it is a placebo,
I don't think it is.
But even if it was,
I liked placebos given give me to me,
giving me a trick me,
trick me with your pet rock trick me.
I'm in this for results.
If you can give me some shit that cures cancer for some fucking crazy reason.
But meanwhile I was just a sugar pill.
Give it to me,
give it to me.
They should sell pills and placebo in it and just call it placebo.
I'm not convinced that we have a handle on how the human brain works.
By the way,
we're going to talk to David Lipton about this.
He's going to actually come on the podcast and talk to us about it,
uh,
about this subject.
So we're,
we're setting that up and he's a way smarter than us on all these subjects.
The fucking Joe Rogan experience is ready to drop on going old school.
It's just me and Brian today.
Oh,
robotics.
[inaudible]
Steve Jobs.
Feminine essence from beyond the grave.
That's what that is.
That's what it seems like.
We were just talking about the apple TV the other day in New York Times today.
They have apple TV with Siri.
Uh,
2013.
They think it's going to be,
that's all rumor right now though,
right?
That's crazy though.
We were just talking about what,
two days ago?
Well,
didn't we read about it?
No,
I'm just,
I,
I is it just speculation did something in his biography about he's figured out
the TV and then I just like,
Hey Siri,
TV seems like it would make it so,
so yeah.
So you read the whole biography already?
No,
no.
I'm still reading it right now.
It's a lot of people are angry with him.
A lot of people are saying because the cup to the fleshlight in case you
wondered what was a gentleman that's put that away,
put that away.
A lot of people like going,
God,
he's such a Douche bag.
Like he like he accomplished so much.
Yeah.
I had this brilliant vision.
He followed through and create the greatest computers,
known demand.
But everybody just keeps saying he's a douchebag.
Well,
you have to be true though.
I thought you didn't see this is what really bothers me.
Right.
Because I always saw him.
I will.
This guy's fucking cool.
He's like a Buddhist.
He's obviously really intelligent.
He's so beloved.
I mean,
how is there ever been a more beloved CEO?
that guy was a God damn rock star.
Steve Jobs would get out on that stage and those geeks would freak the fuck out.
There was like,
he's here,
he's leading us.
It's like he was leading a movement.
It wasn't just like he's a CEO of a technology company.
He was a part of this apple movement.
And also fueled by that sort of underdog thing that everybody loves.
People love being an underdog man.
They love being in the fucking unknown band,
you know?
Or knowing about the unknown band and going to see them before they broke before
they go mainstream.
People love like small things against the fucking oppressive Microsoft regime.
Fuck you windows.
I'll never,
why windows?
I'll fucking Mac till I die.
There's something weird about that.
And there's some Unix dorks that do that right now and Linux dorks and you know,
so I think it was part of that,
that he would all of a sudden made this,
this little underdog successful and it was blossoming in front of everybody's
eyes.
So you get to tell your friends,
oh yeah,
fucking Max are up 2% this week.
You know,
and like,
you know the number one stock and the stock market and people would,
it would,
it was like really like you're rooting for the fucking buffalo bills.
You know,
it might as well have been some baseball team that you were,
you were on.
It wasn't just this operating system thing and this guy was like a fucking hero
man.
It was like a heroin,
a sitcom or,
or a a TV show rather,
you know,
like he came along and all of a sudden he's leading these people on this fucking
[inaudible] episode adventure where he keeps bringing you cooler and Cooler
Shit,
you know,
and you,
you,
you know,
as long as you,
I'm a Mac person,
I'm down with Mac and then everybody sort of,
you know,
you either became macro PC but if you are Mac boy that's your guy.
You know,
like him being called an asshole and hard to work with and stuff.
He probably had half to be,
he had a vision and no one else is understanding what he's thinking,
but he has to make sure it goes through to like what he's thinking in his head
on paper to a product.
And there's people probably putting their 2 cents and like,
no,
we shouldn't do that.
And it probably was like he was a controlling aspect,
but you know what?
Those all those people right now,
they all fucking get it.
You know,
like the iPhone probably was weird when he first was trying to talk about it.
it's all,
it's like,
look at all the different people working in all the various companies and just
think about this.
How much of yourself are you really,
truly willing to give further your company's success?
How much of yourself do you and how much,
how intelligent are you truly?
How well read are you?
How introspective or you,
how objective are you?
Are you really honest about your own ideas?
Are you immersed in your ego?
And if you don't have a handle on all of those things,
if you don't like have answers to all of those questions.
A guy like Steve jobs comes along and he can do some shit that you can't do.
Okay.
Because that guy will,
he will work til he drops.
He's super fucking smart.
He's done LSD.
He said it was like most important things of his life,
you know.
I mean he had some,
you know,
he had some flaws for sure,
but he was also this,
you know,
it's really like a cliche,
the star that shines twice as bright,
lasts half as long.
But it really almost is.
I mean,
I can't say that he caused his own disease.
Right.
But I can't think that it helps to work like a fucking demon to wear like a man
possessed to live the company he worked on the day he died in the hospital room,
he was finishing off a certain product,
which some are saying the iPhone five some are saying to it,
the Apple TV and that he did on the day he died.
That's so crazy.
I guess he just figured,
fuck it.
I'll just ride this bitch right into the beach.
Yeah.
Amazing.
But what an impact.
You need to think about like the impact that that guy had on all the different,
different human beings who enjoyed his products,
us included.
You know,
we're both Mac Dorks,
you know,
I've considered pcs.
I fuck around with them a little bit.
They're beautiful too.
They have great operating system.
It's way better than the old operating systems,
but God damn it.
If I don't know a million people with viruses,
God damn,
if,
I don't know everybody I talked to,
he's got some new thing where they went to a porn site and now every time they
turn in their fucking computer,
they see dicks.
You know,
it's just,
I mean,
that happens all the time.
Get a bigger dick,
got a bigger Dick and get a bigger dick.
Like God damn it.
You fuck like Dylan infect you with a big Dick Commercial?
Well,
it's kind of like your message board.
Anytime somebody gets pink or anything.
And I like putting the pink room.
If they're really bad,
used to change talktalk's cars,
which is the worst disease Dick we could find on.
I actually asked people to stop doing that because it got obsessive.
I don't want to call anybody out or what.
The one guy did it,
he admitted it was like,
that's me.
I'm like,
dude,
I'm gonna fucking cocktails.
Have you given out?
He'd give it out like hundreds of them and it's so homophobic.
I used to,
but you know,
just to start gesture story,
I don't know if you're going to post anymore,
but he was one that I gave a cocktail or two and he was really a funny photo
because the Dick was so small and what I never told anybody is that every day I
made a little bit smaller,
a little bit smaller,
a little bit smarter.
I told there was no dick and no one ever,
never noticed.
It takes the most ridiculous dedication.
Why did you do that?
I don't know because the days of this,
I think it was like probably seven days,
but it was,
he was,
he was so upset because I think it was one of the first cocktail hours.
He was so upset that,
that he got such a horrible Dick.
Okay,
it's so small.
What the fuck dude?
And that is rude to make people post with an Avatar,
someone's deck.
But some of those guys are dicks.
Right.
You know,
it's like there's no better way to discourage douchey behavior than to punish
people for it.
And it's not like it's a real punishment.
So fucking message board.
You don't have to be there.
You know,
you don't want to be there and I'll stop you there.
But for some people,
man,
you put him in that pink room and they go fucking ballistic on you.
It's fascinating.
It's fascinating to watch.
I mean the,
the,
the special ed room is really a fascinating experiment because it's like the
Stanford prison studies that they did,
you know,
when they like students like pretend to be prison guards and then other
students,
they had to cut though short because people get crazy.
Right.
You know,
they got,
they got nutty and they started behaving as if it was like a real prison.
They've got like really creepy.
They had to like cut the experiments.
Sure.
And it wasn't very many days and it was like seven days or something like that.
I'd have to re reread it over and over again to really get a handle on it.
But the idea that you would tell them that can only post in one form,
now all of a sudden it's like prison.
It's really weird.
It's like the fucking trapped in here.
Meanwhile,
you're on the Internet.
Every,
everyone on the board can read it,
they can read it.
It's just like what's been with what we decided is we're going to have to forums
and one form is essentially uncensored except for I don't all out autoplays or
you can't have autoplays,
you can't trick people.
I can't Rick Roll people,
you know,
nothing stupid like that,
then we'll just ban you.
But other than that,
you can pretty much do whatever the fuck you want unless you're,
you know,
if someone tunes in though and finds out that you're a super content there and
then you're like,
what does this guy even to here for,
what's the point?
And then there'll be,
we'll just ban you.
But I find myself hanging out more in a special ed room than the regular form.
Like I go only to the podcast foreign.
And then once in a while,
good at Special Ed.
Like I don't even go to the regular form.
I probably gone twice in the last year.
Um,
I just started going into the Special Ed Forum recently and checking,
cause some guys actually will post some cool shit.
They're just assholes.
You know,
they'll post some cool shit,
but then they'll get online and call somebody a nigger or call somebody a faggot
and you're like,
okay,
what the fuck?
Come on man,
what are you doing?
There's not a need for this.
This is stupid.
This is like,
you know,
especially when a lot of times it's like no,
no point to escalating.
Like people would just escalate for no reason.
You know?
And I wonder how he's,
if it's like the name shit talking one on one because then we change it for a
little while.
We change it.
I did.
I changed it for a short period of time,
but I don't remember what I called it.
What theme are you on?
Are you on the blue or the black?
I like the blue.
Yeah,
I'm on the black.
I went back to the black and I think in the black it used to be on a sign.
Is that shit talking one on one and then that's it.
That was the art drawing.
I think it was like an old drive through movie movie theater or something.
I can't remember for what people don't know what the fuck we're talking about.
There's you,
when you click on the,
there's like a wink at the pot of money somewhere in the message board that
allows you to choose from different styles of message board.
It's either black with white font or blue with black font.
Right?
Like a really light blue that a lot of people think is gay.
But I like it.
No I'm usually on that.
But I switched back to black.
I like it because it's reminds me of sunny skies,
blue skies,
I like blue skies,
they make me happy.
So I look at that and I like the way it is.
I think there's a direct correlation between like looking at like certain dark
dark colors and having dark thoughts.
You know,
I think there is a correlation between those two.
I think maybe the message board would be less country if people just use the
blue.
Have you ever,
have you ever owned a house or an apartment that just had like really bright
yellow walls?
I like like bright light,
like kitchen,
like bright yellow maybe.
It's so nice.
You always feel happy and clean when you're in it.
Really?
Yeah.
Try it out.
Try it.
Find a room and just paint it bright yellow.
You'll be surprised.
It's weird.
What the fuck is that all about?
It's just exactly what you're saying.
It's just one of those colors.
It makes you feel good.
Yeah.
The Sun obviously.
Right.
And Blue Sky yellow the sun.
Yeah,
that totally makes sense.
You know?
That's what I mean when you talk about people that live in places like Seattle
where it rains constantly.
What's the number one complaint?
They don't get sun.
They get depressed and that's why so many of them commit suicide.
You know what I mean?
That's like a big issue,
man.
It's really a vitamin D deficiency as well.
Apparently your brain,
your body makes vitamin D while you're in the sun,
like while you're in the sun,
your body is producing a vitamin.
It's pretty interesting,
you know?
And uh,
that only happens in your body like that.
You know you could eat it and you can supplement it in pill form,
but you only get it make your body only makes it if you're in the sunlight that
it's really,
really kind of fucking interesting.
You need it,
you know,
it's like important to health.
Before I moved to California,
I lived in his house and every room was a different color.
Like my office was dark,
Crimson Red and my kitchen one is bright yellow,
exact etc. But it's weird.
Each room did have like a certain feel to it when you were in it.
Like the bedroom was black Wallace,
which I thought was the worst idea ever and that was just horrible.
Yeah,
it's horrible looking at the comedy store and sleeping.
That's someone who wants to fuck in the dark if you want to fucking dark walls.
Just darkness.
Yeah.
That's some golf sharing.
Some people want to fuck with the lights out,
you know?
That's weird.
You know?
Have you ever be able to check and she said turn the lights out?
No,
I kind of like it.
Damn.
I don't like it bright though.
I don't like it.
You know,
like it was just like super bright gynecological.
That's what I like it.
I like a like a showroom,
like a car showroom.
Oh Wow.
See,
I think if I manscaped war I wouldn't mind it,
but I feel like it's going to kill the deal.
It probably will.
Probably will.
Did you see the photo of Steven Tyler?
Uh,
we,
we talked about like how I almost slipped and killed myself in the bathtub.
He did it at a hotel room and he slipped and fell and he said that,
you know,
it was just,
he,
you know,
he slipped nothing to it and he,
the photo of him,
he like knocked teeth out.
He's got a black eye.
I don't know if you can see this right here,
but it fucked him up,
man.
That's just from taking a bath and accidentally slipping.
Whoa.
That is nuts.
That picture is fucking nuts,
man.
Holy Shit.
Wow.
Well he got jacked,
clumsy.
Fuck.
Have you ever done it though?
It'd be just like slimy feed or almost fallen backwards,
which is the most terrifying thing,
which is,
you know,
if you fall and hit the back of your head,
that's how people die.
If you're sloppy,
you're tired,
you know,
whatever,
you're not really 100% paying attention,
you know,
Shit.
You could,
you,
you can get slippery.
Bathtubs are fucking dangerous as shit.
I mean,
uh,
especially the old ones,
those cast iron ones.
You know,
if you have an old place and you have a old tub,
those old tubs were fucking iron dude.
I mean,
it's like fallen.
Think about falling backwards and hitting iron.
That's essentially
like getting hit in the head by the world.
You know,
that's what it's like.
The world came down on you and hit you and that's what it's like.
It's like,
fuck man,
you get jacked.
That's like really dangerous.
If you ever watched those fights where people get in street fights,
a lot of videos on youtube and guys get knocked out.
And what's terrifying is when they get knocked out,
they fall back in their head,
hits the concrete.
Whoa.
That's scary,
dude.
I've seen that happen in real life.
It is terrifying.
It's like a bowling ball dropping on the guards.
Terrified.
So dangerous to your head.
Just Bonk,
just skull.
And who knows what the fuck is going on inside that skull?
How much bleeding there is,
how much swelling there is.
I mean your brain,
it's just jam packed.
That one dude's Jack from getting hit in the head and they're saying that he's
at might have brain damage that the vet,
they got shot at the occupy Oakland.
You how fucked is that man?
Cops are targeting the fucking people throwing these,
these uh,
tear gas canisters out on that explode.
Then flash grenades.
There's video of this guy laying on the ground.
Injured people went up to try to help him and they shoot them.
No,
no.
They throw the grenade at them.
Flash bomb.
Athema tear gas bomb after,
you know,
they blow up and they,
if they hit you in the fucking head while they're exploding,
like you can get jacked.
But it's just so sad to see these cops are targeting these people.
It's like,
man,
what is this fucking Chicago in the 60s what the fuck is this?
You know what I mean?
I can't believe that these are our citizens,
that these cops are our friends and our neighbors and our citizens.
These occupy people aren't hurting anybody.
Man.
Your job is to serve and protect and you don't need to protect anybody from
these people.
These people are nonviolent.
They're not hurting anybody to serve and protect.
What part of that is throw a fucking grenade at someone's head.
Especially some guy who did two tours,
a fucking duty,
two tours of duty overseas.
He comes back and he's in critical condition from the fellow citizen of fellow
American throwing a fucking Flashman had out a guy who's paid by this
motherfucker's tax dollars.
That's a sad,
sad statement,
man.
It's sad that people are jumping up and down about this and the politicians
aren't fucking condemning this and that people aren't all over the news saying,
this can never happen again and we need to fucking sit down with these cops and
have a long conversation as to what your fucking job entails.
Your job entails helping people out,
man,
that's what you're here for.
You,
our citizens that have extra power and we give you that extra power so that you
make things nicer.
You're not making things nicer by throwing flash grenades on fucking veterans.
That's not making anything nicer.
And that's the only reason to have cops.
The only reason I have comps is to keep the Douche bags down,
to keep them away from the nice people and then help the nice people in the nice
people in trouble.
That's it.
And when the nice people get angry because the bags are fucking robbing them,
you don't throw grenades at them.
You're fucking cunts.
I can't believe it happened in California also.
There's no joke,
bro.
Yeah,
but like New York City it perfect example,
the the governor or whatever said,
hey,
you know,
get rid of all these protestors in a certain area of New York.
And the cops were like,
no,
we're not.
They're not doing anything bad.
We're not doing this.
I don't think you ever been to Oakland.
Yeah,
I know.
But still,
it's no joke.
You need to go and hang out in Oakland for a little while.
Oh,
next time I needed an abortion,
I'll go there.
Get abortions in La still.
I know want abortions are illegal in the state.
Oakland was still have a voice.
Right?
You'll be able to go there.
Yeah,
but I so like in New York there,
what was that too?
Short dog.
Who is the,
the the,
the pimp.
Goddammit.
Short dog.
What's his name?
Too Short.
Too Short,
that guy show white am I,
I'm like Chevy Chase white in a movie when I'm driving a station wagon.
And that's how white I am.
Short guy's name was,
you know,
short lag.
What's his name?
Too Short,
too short is from Oakland,
you know,
and he's always talking about Oakland.
I Tom McCormick lives in Oakland now.
Oakland is the weirdest combination of like gangsters.
Hi Mccormick lives.
Yup.
Gangsters and hippies and like,
and and weed people.
They call it Oaksterdam.
You know,
they have like Oaksterdam University,
like we don't even know the level of medical weed that the state has reached.
The reason why all these people are clamoring,
and apparently this was just released,
that it wasn't Obama's idea to go after these medical marijuana dispensaries,
right.
It was the attorney general or the whoever the fuck gets to was,
it was,
it was.
It was somebody in California,
one of the rare people in the Senate,
or we're talking,
we're talking so nuts.
I said,
I didn't even know the set it is.
I know what that means.
That's like some of them.
I found it on Twitter,
so I'll,
I'll retweet it or something like that.
But what it is a,
what essentially they're saying is that Obama is not respected enough by these
people,
for them to follow his lead.
What he said when he was in office was that he wants to only attack or only go
after the people that are violating both federal and state law.
Marijuana is illegal across the board federally.
So as long as they were following state law,
he would leave them alone.
And the state law,
you know,
it's fucking,
it's pretty tricky because it's really supposed to be nonprofit.
You know?
I don't,
I don't think you're supposed to be able to make millions of dollars and a lot
of these guys are just fucking balling and I support it 100% but I'm just
stating the facts.
The real true facts is that we don't even know the level of medical marijuana
that's hit like California.
Our area is really like on the outskirts.
The real hive of it is in northern California.
The real hive of it is an Oakland where they're having classes where they're
teaching people how to fucking set grow ops up there.
Like people are signing up for classes and it's like,
you know,
they'd given degrees on how to fucking grow weed.
It's really fascinating shit.
They're taking it to the next level.
They're teaching people how to do it.
They have these big,
and so the government obviously feels threatened by this,
this,
this along
with this whole occupy Wall Street movement.
And Pete when when you get hippies with money,
shit gets dangerous as fuck cause you got to a place like Oaksterdam,
you place like it just,
let's say there was a place they're going to open up in boulder,
I think it was like 30,000 square feet.
It was three stories.
I don't know if it ever opened,
but that was like the people,
people who are proven it,
people in boulder like fine bringing in just not going to bother us.
And when they were doing that,
people are thinking how much money can I place like this bring in millions of
dollars,
millions and millions and millions.
It could be incredible amounts of money if you really stop and think about it.
If they have just radical open commerce on marijuana,
how many people are going to grow their own fucking shit?
Not me.
I'm not,
I don't have that kind of time.
Dude,
I can't be watering plants.
Okay.
I got kids,
I got shit to do.
I've got hobbies.
I don't want to water plants.
It might be interesting if I decided to take it on as a hobby.
But if it,
if I could just go down the street and buy weed at the store,
if I can go to seven 11 and buy some weed,
cause that's how it should,
it could be.
It really could be like that.
And when that happens,
those places,
those places that like those medical marijuana places or whoever,
there's decides to open up like a big flashy emporium of weed,
they can become very wealthy and then they become,
they can become very powerful.
When someone becomes wealthy,
they become powerful.
And as they're seeing people accumulate wealth,
they're trying to stop it and then not trying to stop because they're protecting
anybody.
They're not protecting any civilians.
You know,
by stopping these people from making money.
If these people are making money and paying taxes on it,
you should be happy they're contributing to the economy.
This is good.
This is not bad.
We need to change the law.
You don't need to make it so it's legally,
it's either legal or it's not illegal.
It's legal to sell it to people.
It should be illegal to make money off of it.
You're telling me that marijuana can't make money off of it,
even though it's legal as a drug.
But they can make money off of opium.
They can make money off of heroin,
they can make money off of cocaine and fucking oxycontin's and nicotine and
alcohol.
They can make money off that,
but they can't make money off week.
Fuck you.
This is an injust law.
This is an injust law and it's nonsense.
And the reason why is because they're scared of hippies with money,
hippies with money or dangerous as fuck.
Man.
If you've got a bunch of people,
idealists who really,
truly want to change the world and all of a sudden their richest fuck dude,
things can get slippery,
things can,
it's slippery when we people join together and say,
you've got to recognize the weed dollar.
All right cause there's a stoner dollar out there and it's you and it's me and
it's a lot of other fucking people and we buy shit and we pay shit and we pay
our taxes and we contribute to society and we're not bad people.
And at a certain point in time,
you're going to have to respect that stoner dollar.
Cause if you don't,
that Shit's going to come back and bite you in the ass because there's too many
of us now.
There's too many of us and now because of the Internet,
just like occupy Wall Street,
just like anonymous.
We're United,
we're all United.
Likeminded people are United now.
People who exchange ideas and evolve their own ideas on the internet and share,
share a viewpoint with each other and learn from each other.
We're United now.
This is a different time,
man.
You can't just control people like you used to be able to control people in the
60s and the 70s we couldn't talk to each other.
We had a huddle in our fucking homes at night listening to the radio,
hoping everything was going to be okay.
Well this isn't that day man.
These cops that are staging these fucking fake shootings at schools so they can
check the kids for drugs.
You know,
you're just horse for some pharmaceutical company from some giant conglomerate
and the only reason you're doing that,
it's because the weed dollar hasn't hit you yet.
Once the weed dollar hits you,
you're going to shut the fuck up.
You're going to have to shut the fuck up because the weed people are going to
help the cops that weed people are going to promote,
you know,
a,
a good relationship with the police officers.
They'll contribute just like,
you know,
these fucking,
these giant banks are contributing to occupy Wall Street down in Wall Street.
These banks for four point $6 million was donated to the New York police
department so that they can fucking like look out for all these assholes.
These,
these are rich fucking money thieving cunts.
Think about that,
you know,
wrap wrap,
wrap your head around that.
When the we dollars starts doing that,
two things are gonna change.
Everyone's going to have to look at it that way and they're so terrified of
that.
That is a,
that's something that really could truly change the world.
People who are trippers,
who have money trippers who have money and philanthropy,
philanthropic ideas and the ambition to follow through on them.
And the pharmaceutical companies are terrified of that shit.
Politicians are terrified of that shit,
whether they admit it or not,
they're terrified of that shit on top of the fact that you have to say you don't
like drugs because everybody thinks about the children and it's saying you like
drugs is just too controversial to many people are ignorant.
They don't get it.
So it's like saying you don't like tools.
To me it's like I don't want tools.
We're going to just leave things the way they are.
Yay.
Do you think it's a certain age group that's just going to die off though
eventually and then it's going to be more accepted and say like 10 to 20 years?
You know why?
Yes.
And you know why?
Because of this,
because of things like this podcast,
because of the Twitter,
because of Facebook,
because of,
you know,
Mark Marin's Blah or a podcast or a should fears podcast to all the death squad
pod,
all that free talking people,
people who are allowed because of this sort of a format to express themselves in
a way uncensored that millions of people you can get.
I mean you good or bad,
you can make a youtube video like that video of the lady sitting on the toilet
there were watching the other day,
terrible,
but 38 million eyes have seen that man.
38 million people have seen that.
That's incredible.
I mean that's amazing that you can do that.
Now.
There was,
there's never been a time in human history where you could do anything that can
almost immediately be recognizing and seen by so many people through Twitter,
through Facebook,
through blogs and podcasts.
And this is the shit that's changing the world,
man.
This is what's changing the world.
Free Open communication.
They,
this is where the government truly fucked up.
It's not what drugs.
Cause the problem with free open communication is we go,
why not drugs?
If it was just drugs and we didn't have free open communication and the,
the reality is this is not much you can do if you can't communicate with each
other.
It's hard to organize things.
It's hard to get a movement going.
It's hard.
You know,
you have to have a person who's a leader and that person
gets arrested.
You can never have the type of situation right now the occupy Wall Street,
this hive mind situation,
this exists solely because of the internet and it never existed before.
This is where there's a total different sort of revolution going on right now.
And essentially what's happening is we're setting the stage for the next
generation in a big,
big,
big way because the next generation is not going to be these cops throwing flash
grenades anymore.
It's going to be cops that have to realize that to be a police officer,
you're just,
another one of us were just,
you're just one of us that we'd give a weapon so that you protect people and
when you stop doing nice things and you start being a problem,
you can't be a company more.
It's not,
there's no union thing.
There's no,
we got our rights and we go to fucking labor thing and you go to sit down with a
mediator.
No,
no,
you can't do that.
You can't be that.
That's not what a police officer is.
That's not a bank or can't steal from you.
You can't charge 30% entrance.
You fuck heads.
You can't not have the money when the shit hits the fan because you've invested
it shittily you know there's these things.
Things cannot be variables and that is,
the stage is being set right now.
That's the stage is being set in our generation.
Our generation is setting the stage for the next generation,
the generation that is going to grow up and evolve from birth to death with the
Internet.
That's a different generation than us.
You know,
you and I are from the,
we're we're dinosaurs,
man.
Where we were around when answering machines where the,
the shit you're going to be that there's probably going to the next generation,
the generation to come.
It's probably going to get to the point where it's something like there's going
to be a cat as a president or something like that.
You know,
like we nominated frisky over here and he somehow one because why not frisky
doesn't have any skeletons in his closet.
Know first.
He's never,
you know,
and he's just the face of a nation,
he's not really doing any of that.
Wouldn't work the fuck.
Might as well have the face be cute.
It could be Dora,
Dora the explorer can be our president.
You know,
Dora the explorer or Sarah Pailin.
Who would make the better choices?
Dora at least would look at the screen and go,
what are you guys think?
Yeah,
we're going to send drones in the Pakistan.
We don't need to waste soldiers.
We can shoot them from the air.
That's how Dora the explorer would be the president.
Really?
Sarah Palin's you to tell your pussy.
I bet you she's had a bunch of kids.
Man,
that thing's probably a wreck Dora,
but I bet she gives up the ass.
Did you?
I see that monks,
I showed you the shots of Jack Daniels.
A little cocaine in her.
Which Lindsay Lohan Mugshot.
Would you fuck?
Yeah.
Lindsay Lohan got arrested again and her dad got arrested again.
God Damn.
If you had to pick one though,
which one would it be?
Oh,
fuck off him.
I was drunk.
I know.
No one.
You have to choose one.
I would probably go with the one,
uh,
second to the right.
I would go with the far right.
The palest one.
Oh,
the scary one.
I think she looks hot and ready to go in that picture.
She looks,
it's fascinating that that was unsear that I tweeted about this.
That was on CNN front fucking page news about him getting arrested and I'm like,
really?
If it's,
is it on your front page,
your website?
Some guy who's a shitty dad got arrested.
Michael Lohan,
really?
You Care,
you care.
You fucking really care.
Why are you showing me this?
You Dragon the dragon characters into my plot that I don't need.
You don't need them in my,
my show.
Yeah.
And the only reason I like about my life then I'm watching.
Don't you think Lindsay Lohan would be the perfect person to date to try to
change?
Really?
No.
It doesn't seem like I can change you.
I can make,
I can get you out of all of this.
Can't change.
You can't change your vigil.
I mean,
if you were on the same level,
no.
You'd have to be really,
really rich man.
How many people were as Rich's Lindsey fucking Lohan Richie's doing.
You're crazy.
Boy.
Listen man,
they're offering her $1 million.
Fleshlight is to make a mold out of her box slash light off.
So now our boys.
Yes,
please.
So we could have Lindsay Lohan on.
Yeah,
we'll talk about it.
She won't come on this podcast.
She couldn't come here.
We'd have to bring it to your place to say I was a lesbian.
This is Rebecca.
Doesn't want that.
Skank hang around here.
But uh,
I think she's still rich,
man.
I think she's,
unless she's just been horribly mismanaged court costs though that she's been
going through so much.
Coke came probably maybe her court problems aren't like murder or shit.
They're like really drains you financially because you have to establish some
sort of a case.
It's for getting in trouble for shit.
There's really not much court work.
I mean,
not much legal work they can do to try to squeeze her out of it.
She's a fucking coke ad and she gets drunk.
She gets fucked up.
She,
she,
she likes to party man.
And we said this before,
she's a 20 whatever the fuck she is.
25 2050 she's died.
I think she should really,
I think she's just find out how will it,
is Lindsey alone?
I would say she's 23 really 20 yeah.
22 or 2125
Michael Lohan,
would you fuck,
she's 25 she's 25 I'm right.
So 25 and she looks like 25 in dog years.
That's just age and hard.
Whatever.
I,
she looks,
she does look hot,
but so does Jimmy Moore and she's like 48 and I was shit lately.
Let me show you a photo being nice dark photos over.
I don't want to see it.
I don't want to see it all go away.
What happened?
How did she,
how did she just lost her grip on the magic?
I don't know.
She couldn't find the little girl to sing too.
I think it's like tangled with the magic hair.
I don't know.
I don't know what the rumor is.
That was that there'd be more joke.
What the rumor is?
What?
What'd you say?
Never.
Nothing.
Alright.
You've got a photo over with she looks back.
Hold on.
I'm looking at,
I'm trying to find it.
Google to me more looking bad.
Me More arms or arms.
Yeah,
I think we talked about it on a podcast.
So already there's this horrible photo that was at recently.
Um,
it's like when people were like shitting on Megan Fox thumbs,
they'll look luminar thumbs up or thumbs like,
bitch,
what are you talking about?
That's one of the hightest women that's ever walked the face of the planet.
And you're,
you're looking at her thumbs.
You could,
she could chop those fucking thumbs off machetes and replaced them with eagle
cause it could be an eagles talent on each hand.
And I wouldn't mind,
I feel a little weird.
Here's what,
grabbing my deck with an Eagle Talon for a thumb though.
I guess it's not odd.
I found it,
but it gets,
it's not all.
It's actually that she has,
she's anorexic looking like she like it.
You're starting to be able to see like how creepy her arms are.
Uh,
there's another shot that her hand,
I think it's
this one dude.
She's just fit.
She's got muscle.
That's the muscle.
She's,
she's very thin,
but she's got muscle.
She's probably,
I don't like some fucking crazy,
Ooh,
that looks real skinny,
but she's fucking 48 years old or whatever the hell she is.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well you do start their women's start losing fat in their face and that's one of
the things that really bums them out.
So they get fillers and it's really kind of fucking creepy.
Fillers are really dark,
man.
It's really kind of a weird thing when people do,
they shove like,
I don't know what it is,
some stuff in your fucking mug and it,
you know,
like when you see women with like really puffy cheeks and shit,
but I think she still looks hot as fuck man.
I look at that picture right there and my,
she's pretty hot dude.
She just looks fit to me.
She looks thin but fit.
She's probably just on a really healthy diet.
Yeah.
You'd
cut off their hair though.
It's like Steve Jobs in that photo where he's wearing a dress though,
kind of Steve jobs where he went,
oh,
she's not that thing.
You're crazy man.
She looks healthy,
she looks healthy,
but she looks like a person is probably fanatical about exercise.
Yeah.
Look man.
Do you want to keep it together at that age?
I just worked out today with Steve Maxwell.
Steven Maxwell's is Kettlebell guy that I'm friends with and he'll,
he comes over like a few times a year and puts me through these brutal workouts.
Wow.
And uh,
yeah,
he's an animal bro.
And he's 59 years old,
50 fucking nine years old,
and he can do some shit that I can't do.
He could do a bunch of different exercises I can't do.
He puts me through these wild fucking yoga positions and it makes you do chin
ups where you,
you will fully extend,
pull your chin up all the way up and then you hold it for five breaths and then
you go to your eyeballs,
you hold it to him for five breaths and then you go above your head and you hold
it for five breaths and then you go fully extended and then you pull yourself
back up and start all over again.
And it takes a long time.
It takes like 90 seconds to do like three of them.
And when you're doing this man,
he does it like it's nothing and he's fucking 59 years old.
Fuck that.
The dude's a stud.
He,
he can,
he can put it,
it's amazing.
Some people can fucking,
they just keep it together.
But the only way you do it like that,
like he's a world renowned fitness instructor.
He works out every day.
He's teaching people,
he's training every fucking day of his life,
like literally.
And he's training people how to train everyday of his life.
So he just maintains fitness,
like to,
to look like Demi Moore and basically essentially 50 years old.
Yet I guess they're saying that she lost 98 pounds up to 98 pounds of what she
used to weigh.
That's what they're saying.
Oh,
you making up a number?
No,
it's right here.
This is reported to have plummeted to around seven stone.
That's 98 pounds for all you folks on this side of the pond.
That doesn't mean she lost 98 pounds.
That means she changed.
As I said,
plummeted.
I just,
this is a little baby going to help you.
So good news.
I have something to announce.
A,
you already know about it already about dust squad.
We are moving to the Pasadena Ice House.
The studio.
Yeah.
So we're going to set up a professional studio out there so that all the lie
from the Ice House shows and all the desk watches and uh,
I talked to,
we talked to was the fleshlight about sponsoring the death squad show and the
Ice House show.
And if they don't,
well somebody else will and just holler at us on Twitter and we'll figure
something out.
Only legit companies don't get crazy with your pipe dreams.
Work it all out on your own before you come to us.
Cause Shit ain't cheap.
But uh,
if uh,
we do set up that uh,
set up,
uh,
the,
um,
the studio there at the podcast or the podcast studio where they're at a ice
house,
it'd be amazing because it's really like right around the corner from the stage,
from both stages and you can just get offstage,
run out,
do a set,
come back and do the podcast.
And we did it one time and I thought it was really fun and people liked it.
It's a fun energy.
Also there was a,
I just,
I don't know if you saw that there was like 20 minutes of extra footage that we
recorded.
Me and Brendan that later that night that we were so wasted I didn't remember
doing and I found it.
I put it up.
But you're in it too.
And we talked to the guy that made the Burke Chrysler tee shirts.
Was that?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
Towards the very end.
And then some guy that said he was going to verify me on Twitter anyways,
that's up on,
I just put up the podcast.
Yeah.
You need to verify them.
Whoever you are are,
boy,
I don't think they do that anymore though.
Really?
Yeah.
I think they stopped that whole thing.
Maybe you just want it to be your friend,
so he pretended he could verify you.
It'd be a cool thing to say,
Hey,
I can verify your baby.
Give me your number.
Yeah,
let me look it up,
sweetie.
What's up?
Want to get verified.
Hmm.
That's a new,
that's,
I'm gonna try that.
It's very important to be verified on Twitter and you know,
there's a lot of fake people.
There's a lot of like,
I don't think Chris Rock's really on Twitter.
It might be now.
He wasn't for a long time though.
Yeah,
there's a lot of,
I don't think Chappelle's on,
no,
I don't think so.
I think that's fair.
Yeah,
I'm pretty sure.
And I think the fake ones got a lot of people on it.
They think it's unfortunate,
uh,
tells on Twitter.
But he only used it like nine times ever.
But he started,
he tweeted something about his new shows.
Good.
What does a Dave's old porn on showtime.
Do you know anything about that now?
He an issue.
I didn't even know you had a new show.
Well,
he's coming on next Tuesday,
so he'll tell us what the fuck is up.
And then,
uh,
Shane Smith from Vice TV.
We're going to get him on hopefully sometime next week.
Right.
But that guy,
man,
that's going to be the nuttiest conversation ever.
That guy has been everywhere.
He seen some crazy and he said he's got some
nutty slave footage to show us.
What?
Yeah,
yeah.
I don't,
I'll tell you exactly what he said.
It sounds,
it sounds pretty fucking nutty.
Missed the slave.
He's,
um,
you know,
he's one of those dudes,
it's like he's out there and like the darkest parts of the world like all the
time filming it and bringing it back.
Like they're like living on the edge of the edge of the edge,
you know,
that's a,
that's a crazy ass fucking show.
And this guy is one of the craziest,
he seems to embrace it.
It's really interesting.
You know why he's all,
I mean when they were in Liberia and they were running around,
it was like,
fuck,
we almost got killed,
but it could have been dead.
They will like almost laughing about it.
He said he's got some end slave footage that will blow your mind.
I'll bring you encase leads,
but I'm not sure what that means.
And Kay and Kay.
Anybody,
Bueller,
Kerrigan.
I don't know what it means,
but whatever slave footage,
um,
I want,
I want to say that whatever,
whatever fucking craziness he's got.
He,
they,
they're in there.
I told you about the Congo one,
you gotta wash that Congo one.
I don't know,
I've only watched one episode of it,
but just the one episode which leads sort of just get things cooking.
They're just,
you look at the reality of that area and you saw all my God like this is cool.
This is Fuck Mad Max Mad Max.
If they were living in Mad Max and they saw this,
they'd be like,
dude,
that's terrifying.
Like Mad Max Times.
It looks like like a break from the Congo.
You'd be like,
oh we have to do is fight for gasoline and stay away from thunder dome and
everything's cool.
You know,
and you look at Liberia,
you look at the Congo and you look in all these places like these fucking dirt
roads and like hot and people pile into the street and just looks like,
like you went back in time.
It's like you like Yo,
you went back in time to like some dark age when people,
people were still developing humanity and developing culture and developing,
you know,
a community,
the sense of community and you just shoved them all together.
And gave them houses and gave them clothes and cars.
And it's just,
it's almost like,
it's like you can't believe that there's a part of the world that's that,
that nuts.
And when they were given the figures about the Congo,
but how many people have been murdered there?
You just go,
what box?
It's like millions of people.
Millions.
And just think of the idea of a million being a thousand,
a thousand times.
I think about there's multiple,
multiple millions and millions of people have died in the Congo.
And think about the,
just the,
the,
the enormity of the mass of all those bodies together.
And you realize how crazy it is.
These fucks went there and they went there to film the fucking video.
Oh my God.
It's nuts,
dude.
Everyone's got guns and machine guns and AK 47 and there,
there's minors and they're fucking putting people through slave labor to get
them to pull out,
you know,
rocks and minerals that we're gonna use to make cell phones.
It's,
the world is crazy as fuck right now.
And it,
a lot of it is just we know,
you know,
a lot of it is just we know we're constantly inundated by information.
When I was a kid,
if you wanted to find out about EDI mean you gotta you got to do some searching.
You know,
you got to go to a library,
you had to buy a book,
you had to talk to a teacher.
You know Mr. Johnson Q.
Explain to me how EDI mean rose to power.
I was a long story could and he,
you know,
you,
you couldn't just get the information but like Kadafi man,
we watched that guy's last moments of life.
You know,
think about the difference in the leap of information between now and 2030 years
ago.
We watched Kadafi died.
I watched a guy shove a stick up Qaddafi's ass while he was covered in blood.
I saw him with no blood on him.
I heard gunshots and I see him bleeding in the fucking head.
Yeah.
They pissed a whip.
That dude that kicked him.
You see him kicking him.
We watched that.
Yeah.
It's weird that the,
it's weird that that happened because they aren't,
they fighting for,
you know,
like religious reasons,
like God,
you know God and stuff like that and they're,
they're doing something that,
you know,
their guide,
it's like against what they believe in.
What you're trying to say is that when they were doing it,
they say,
oh,
ah,
I know what they're singing.
They're saying God is great.
God is great.
You're cheering.
God is very religious people,
but yet they're murdering and torturing and it seems,
yeah,
so stupid.
Well,
not only that,
they were parading him around on a truck and they were holding him down with
shoes because shoes to them or like really disrespectful.
Oh,
right.
Throwing a shoe at the president.
Yeah,
I remember that.
That was the one time where it illuminated to me how much of it is just a job
for George Bush.
He's just a guy with a job.
When that guy started throwing the shoes at him and he had a little smile on his
face,
he's like,
Gee Whiz,
finally I get a little fun on the job.
Right.
But he had a little fun on the job today.
Normally my job is bullshit and to people while Dick Cheney fucks the world,
but today I got the ducks
shoes,
honey.
It was fun.
I was like,
come on you little fella.
You ain't got no fucking arm.
Throw it.
Throw no shoes.
It's like he seemed human to me for like a brief moment because to me Bush was
always this moron.
It like stood on a battleship with,
you know,
mission accomplished in the background when fucking nothing had been
accomplished.
Like you're talking crazy.
What are you going to call it first and then we win the war.
The fuck are you talking about?
How's it mission accomplished?
Was 100,000 fucking troops over there and you know,
50,000 deadly war machine circling the sky,
dropping bombs on people.
What the fuck are you talking about?
What was your mission?
Mission accomplished.
We stolen lied.
You know,
if that's what their mission accomplish was,
we got over there,
we got Halliburton contracts,
we did it,
we did it.
We,
we sold the weapons of mass destruction lie,
Yay,
mission accomplished.
Then it's mission accomplished.
So I always looked at him as being,
this is fucking new world order mouthpiece,
this,
you know,
this evil person who is perpetrating these things on the American people.
And then I looked at him when that guy was throwing a shoe at him and I was
like,
he's just a guy,
is the normal guy.
Just a guy who got duped.
And the reason why he comes off dom is because part of the reason why he's
weighed now than when he was the governor.
If you go back and listen to,
like George Bush had speeches,
George Bush jr w when he was a young man and he was campaigning for governor,
he was quite eloquent.
I mean,
it's really a shocking difference between that level of,
of,
of the ability to communicate that he had back then and how he came across as,
you know,
maybe not the most educated guy in the world,
but at least he was focused and prepared and he spoke very clearly and he seemed
very confident.
Whereas you see him like as a an older man,
it's like he just barely fucking phoning it in and that's what it was like.
He was like Jack on lost in the last season.
Who's phoning it in?
He was just tired of the whole charade and he was forced into that position and
so that's why he said stuff with the knife,
no passion behind it.
Like the evil doers,
he would say like stupid shit because he would get off script and he really
didn't have any passion for it,
so he didn't have,
it's not even that he was dumb.
He said he never thought about it.
He's like,
he had to shut himself off of the reality of what being the fucking president
was because everybody,
when they're a little boy,
thinks that the reality of being the president is all you get to be the fucking
guy who fixes everything and be the next Teddy Roosevelt would be the guy who
turns America around.
Meanwhile,
all you are is just strapping a condom on this giant machine,
this giant war machine as it fucks America in the ass,
and that's what you're doing.
You're there to provide the condoms so American doesn't know what the fuck is
happening.
You know,
you're,
you're there to the,
to put the put on the show.
You're there to tell everybody that everything is okay.
We have to insert this dick in your ass to fight terror.
Oh,
okay.
You know,
it's like,
that's what he was,
he was the mouthpiece,
the mouthpiece for the monster and that guy throwing the shoe at it just
illuminated it.
I saw him with a glimmer in his eye,
like a young guy again and meanwhile he's just a fucking 60 year old man,
60 year old man who just got sucked into the wrong fucking crowd.
Never really was ambitious,
never really cared that much.
If you look at his past,
he was like a lazy guy.
So when all of a sudden he's in a position,
boy,
he's going to be set for life financially.
He's fucking president now.
He's even in his second term,
like he just had no ambition.
You're talking about a guy who choked himself unconscious on a pretzel and fell
and knocked himself out.
You remember that Shit.
You had like a black eye or that was a story that totally seems like the most
ridiculous story ever.
Maybe his dad beat the fuck out of them.
Could you imagine if he was like doing something wrong or he said something
wrong and his dad put on leather gloves and like beat him and fries.
They'll put on like SAP gloves.
Just beat his ass in front of everybody to show him like,
this is not how the new world order's run and just fucking beat his ass,
you know,
just to let them know,
motherfucker,
we're crazy.
All right,
we're really the throat planes into buildings or I will punch you right in the
fucking face.
I wouldn't put it past on him.
His Dad was the head of the fucking CIA.
His Dad,
they always thought he was like a Wimp,
you know,
like there was like the big thing on,
on the older Bush,
you know,
I was like,
oh well the wimp president.
And like,
you know,
they look,
it was on a,
like Newsweek.
I was reading very recently.
Um,
he was on the cover of Newsweek and it was talking about him being a wimp and it
was like a very controversial thing because here's a guy who's,
you know,
I'm going to run the fucking biggest nuclear power in the free world.
And they're saying,
is he a wimp?
Like,
wow,
like that's a label,
man.
You stick that and a magazine,
a fucking magazine sticks that.
But meanwhile,
this guy was the head of the fucking CIA.
You know what kind of Evil Shit you have to do to be the head of the CIA to get
to the top of that monster.
The CIA's a shadow government.
We have a shadow government that is allowed to murder people.
They're allowed to go out of the country and murder people.
You know,
whether or not you call these people terrorists or whether or not you can
connect them to illegal activity.
The bottom line is the CIA,
including American civilians.
The CIA goes over there and kill these motherfuckers and,
and they don't do shit about it.
Nobody does a fucking thing about it.
The government doesn't prosecute him.
They don't go after him.
For these,
these drone attacks that they do.
They do some crazy shit,
man.
And this guy was the head of that.
He was the head so maybe he didn't have to fucking lay the gloves to George
Little Georgie.
Skim a fucking stiff jab in the face.
Bitch will fucking kill you.
This is how it works.
No,
you can't go back to own a baseball team,
right?
Yeah.
And he throws a pretzel down on him and hits him in the face of,
yes,
you have to say that you choked on his bitch or something like that.
Like you have to make it seem like they'd most like bitchy
being they get a black car.
Maybe he was trying to get some head from a tranny.
I found out that it was a training and then the trainee beat his ass and he
couldn't say anything cause he was a president.
Training Lips,
carbs.
It could be.
Did you hear about the blacklist bill that that they're,
they're trying to pass a black list called the blacklist bill and it pretty much
will make like Twitter,
youtube,
Facebook,
like those companies be 100% responsible for the content so it could kill pretty
much killed Twitter,
anything like that.
Fucking con it would make it a felony to,
to stream unlicensed content,
video game play throughs,
like a karaoke songs,
music videos,
like all that shit.
And I go make it a felony.
So Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
What the fuck.
So it's pretty much going to start censoring.
The Internet's going to start it.
Who is allowing people to continue to come up with?
Can we have a moratorium on new laws?
Just like obviously shit is spiraling out of control.
There's a million new laws introduced every year that upset people that we don't
have a chance to truly reconcile and understand and,
and,
and just talk about,
you know,
just a dress.
There's too many of them.
There's new ones every day,
whether it's medical marijuana,
they're trying to do this to try and do that with vitamins and fucking make them
prescription only to try to do this,
to try and do that.
It's,
it's a constant stream of bullshit.
You fucking criminals and I hope,
I hope that it doesn't through Bhs stop free speech.
They're trying to stop people from doing what they're doing now,
which is organizing.
When do you think they are going to start making a sensor?
Podcasts.
They can't.
I think they're not because there's too many of them.
There's too many of them.
There's too much.
It's too much going on.
What does the sensor censorship for?
If it's free and you actually have to download it and it's,
you know,
it's labeled mature,
it seems to be fucking pretty simple.
Unless you're going to start censoring movies and censoring songs,
which you know they've tried,
they've tried in the past and it essentially they do censor movies because if
you go above are,
you can't have any sexual content and movie,
like real interaction.
Do you remember Brown bunny?
Do you remember that movie?
No.
It was a Vincent Gallo movie and it was what?
That,
I forget that chicks chicks name.
So there's a van g Chloe Shalane going game anyway.
She sucks his cock for real man.
Really?
Yeah.
That's part of the plot.
Part of the plot was like,
it's just like this really hot scene.
And they said,
well,
we're just going to really do it,
so really act it out.
So.
So she no,
no.
Chloe,
Chloe.
Yeah.
You watched the scene,
you'll just,
just Google seen from Brown bunny.
Wow.
And you know Vincent Gallo is standing up and he pulls out his dick and Chloe's
stuff.
I can go there and eat.
How did you say her name is?
She,
she sucked his cock and the nuts in her face and it's 100% legit.
Wow.
First of all,
his cock is not that impressive.
Are they dating at the time?
I think they were.
That makes sense.
Or that might've been just what they put on the press release to make it seem
not so bad.
Well,
they are dating,
you know?
Wow.
Yeah.
So,
I mean,
but,
and everybody got mad at them for that by the way.
And he sort of blacklisted because of that.
Wow.
Yeah.
He doesn't really work that much and he's really a good actor,
but he's really,
he seems to be really crazy.
He's like a real dark weirdo sort of a character.
And I remember he was,
he's been in like vodka ads and shit and he's always the guy with like long sort
of greasy hair and there's a bunch of dirty heroin looking girls around.
I'm looking at suck dicks.
Ever seen those pictures?
Yeah.
Well that's him and he's just,
he's fucking,
he's a weird guy.
I mean to do that and think it's okay to do that and I move it.
I'm just going to pull macaca you suck it for real.
Okay.
Yeah.
We're going to leave this in yo watts.
You gotta leave in the cock sucking part.
How can we can't just imply it,
man.
I mean,
sexy enough,
you know,
just seeing her head and seeing though,
you don't have to actually show your Dick.
And I'm how long showed all,
man,
that's what's really going on.
I want to show what's happening.
I want to show how to be realist,
the realist of the real.
But at one point in time,
you know that was where people thought it was going to go.
When deep throat came out,
people got in line like and went to that on Bates deep throat came out and it
was like a real movie that was a pornographic movie and that had really not been
fucking popular before that,
you know,
they're really,
I mean there was behind the green curtain or door with Marilyn Chambers.
That was one that was like along similar lines and there's like a picture from
that I saw online of Johnny Carson waiting in line for deep throat.
Apparently they were interviewing him and he'll just like,
it was like acceptable to go and see this and go see this.
This movie where people actually fucked because it was a movie they had.
They didn't have porno movies like that.
So because it was a movie,
they trick people and all of a sudden people were in this movie watching some
checks,
sucks some decks.
You know,
it's kind of crazy when you think about it.
That wasn't that long ago.
And you've got to wonder what if things,
uh,
you know,
weren't,
maybe they loosened up quicker.
You know,
what,
what if,
if that was introduced today,
what if we never had porn before and we have this sort of crazy environment
where we have right now.
And then all of a sudden someone started,
it would be porn used to be just like scenes,
but then someone put together a real good movie where people actually fucking
it.
And it was like the first one ever done like man,
and maybe it was an idea before its time because you gotta think of Johnny
fucking Carson who's like,
you know,
the weird head of the tonight show,
hit me as America Pie as you can get,
as across the board,
normal as you can get.
And he's waiting in line to see deep throat.
Well you would have to hide that pee wee Herman.
Just a few decades later,
it goes to jail for beating off in a theater.
You know,
it's,
and it's sought thought of as being really ultra CD,
like,
oh my God,
he went to a theater when they were playing pornographic movies.
This is just a few decades later,
man.
It's interesting.
It could,
I wonder what could have happened.
I wonder if it's one of those things where we just as zigged when we could have
zagged,
you know,
and maybe when that happened,
they could've started doing,
like,
there could have been like a normal genre.
Like you'd go to see,
you know,
a fucking Jennifer Aniston movie and it was an ex,
Jennifer Aniston would get fucked.
Gerard Butler would just fucking dig in that.
There'll be craziest shit if you watch a real movie.
Like that's stupid fucking movie they had where one of them was,
uh,
a convict or something.
They're handcuffed together.
How much better would that movie be of Jennifer Aniston was talking as deck,
of course,
be a way better moving.
It'd be a way better movie.
It would be fun.
You know,
it'd be like,
damn,
that girl's got a great mouth.
It'd be fun.
You know that big Chin really aids when she's blowing you because it gives you
like extra coverage of your balls on her chin.
It's like more chin to go around.
That's how you would look at it.
It'd be fun,
but instead it didn't go that way.
You can imagine if the porno stars are the ones that made the big cash,
that was like the real,
those are real money and if you didn't,
if you were,
if you're a hot chick and you're too scared to do porn,
yeah,
well you know,
and you'd be on a Sitcom I guess,
which you couldn't do any movies.
The real big money movies that people want to watch people fuck.
That could been really easily been possible.
If you look at how God damn popular pornography is,
it's really just a matter of a public attitude about it because pornography is
gigantic on the Internet.
I mean they think something like 30 to 40 of all packages that are flying around
being downloaded on the internet,
have some sort of pornography on them.
That's amazing.
I mean,
that's a,
just a staggering number.
When you think about the billions of human beings on the Internet,
I mean,
how many billions or on the internet worldwide,
is it like four or something like that?
There's like almost 7 billion people.
Let's be conservative and say it's 3 billion on the Internet.
You think that's conservative or think that's like,
let's go crazy and say 2 billion.
Let's say it's only 2 billion people online.
That's a lot of fucking people.
2 billion people and 30 to 40% of it is just dicks in pussies and sucking cock
and that's all it is.
It's amazing.
Then when you stop and think about the demand,
the sheer demand,
and yet when you look around,
you wouldn't know when you go to the movies,
it's not represented.
It's is not.
You go to the magazine store,
it's not represented.
Sure.
There's some like weird shit up at the top that sealed off and plastic and
they're so fucking big,
you know,
subscription thing over the front cover.
So you can't even see what it's in there until you open the plastic and yeah,
it's a sort of represented,
but not 30 to 40%.
Not even close.
It's not.
It's like 1% maybe of the,
all the magazines at a Barnes and noble,
you know,
1% of them may be or pornographic.
It's even in there.
They're never like hardcore either.
It's just like they show you like tits and shit.
They show you like a little little spread apart if you're lucky girls,
peanut on somebody.
No.
That's why I can't understand why like magazines like playboy or giving $1
million to Lindsay Lohan when you know how the Internet works nowadays.
If Lindsay Lohan,
there's a photo of her from playboy.
Everybody's going to have it in like two seconds.
Yeah.
They're counting on the rubes.
The count on the people that just can't get online quick enough.
They don't know anybody with the forum.
The forum,
I go on the forum and then what do I do it?
They don't know that.
They don't know what they're doing.
Man,
they're just fucking knuckleheads.
I feel bad for the board on vacation.
Maybe.
I feel bad for my mom cause she,
she recently,
she,
they still don't have internet at her house,
you know,
like Dsl.
So she now got a hot spot phone,
a smart phone that has a hot spot so she can get on the Internet through her
phone,
you know.
Wow.
So it's stupid.
It's shit.
It's not even a four g phone.
She's a three g and a,
so now she's,
she's has fast I internet and we wouldn't have had the internet or like a whole
life.
And even when porn started coming up,
it used to be like really slow loading porn.
So it's like,
oh my God,
there's the bottom of balls.
When we were talking about that in the last podcast with that guy that got
caught who was doing the gay porn and that,
my friend actually had to sit in a room with them and download the picture as a
picture is downloading.
Yes.
He's more of his head and then he sees a dick in his mouth.
Yeah.
Well,
it's funny how that sequence,
we kind of,
you know,
she now just go to a website by mistake and it's like buttholes assholes calm
shots instantly.
Instantly.
Yeah.
She has no,
no.
And she had,
it doesn't have any kind of like warning or training for the Internet as a
windows computer too doesn't she's.
Yes.
And she's
already installed everything.
Putting,
put her social security number
signed up for Netflix three times somehow.
Oh No,
I told you about the time that somebody hacked me on Twitter.
They'll tell you about that happens all the time,
man.
I got it yesterday because somebody sent me like a,
hey check out this photo of you.
I can't believe you have that in your mouth.
And I'm like,
what?
And I click on it and then the website turned to I Twitter but it looked exactly
like Twitter and had me log in.
Of course I didn't it,
I didn't do it.
Well,
yeah,
with me.
I had to I to look at something,
I think I had to click on something and somehow or another,
you know there's a lot of times when you like install like quick vid are all
these little,
little,
you know,
picked Vic and the little little fucking websites and software that runs videos
and pictures.
There's like some user agreements that they're creepy like they're allowed to
like use your Twitter and tweet shit.
Yeah Dude,
this is fucking tweet.
It said on my,
on my Twitter I that I just entered a contest for an iPad two and I looked at
that and someone said,
what do you [inaudible] is this spam?
Like someone was saying it's spam,
you know,
are you,
did you really enter the for an iPad two and I want to what?
So I go to my timeline.
When I was busy,
I wasn't,
I wasn't online,
I wasn't doing shit.
Somehow or another through my Twitter,
they had tweeted that I had signed up for a contest,
which I never signed up for a contest in the link.
When you click the link was this scam website,
do you think?
Uh,
do you remember like doing one of those where like,
oh,
I got to login?
No,
I did not log in.
I don't know how the fuck they did it.
I don't know what they did.
That's weird.
I did not.
No,
I did not log in and it was a new program that I had somehow or another that
recently got on my Twitter and on top of that they fought.
I fought,
was following them on Twitter and I did not follow them.
They,
they followed,
they put that in my Twitter.
They made me follow them and they made a tweet.
So I had to change my password,
but I went to it.
I went to the website and the guy had like 100,000 fucking hits.
Wow.
And would you report it?
Yeah.
Yeah,
I did.
He had 100,000 followers on his as Twitter site and I was like,
this is incredible.
I've never heard of this guy.
He's got 100,000 fucking followers.
And you know,
I,
I tweeted online,
I'm not going to say the guy's name,
I'm not going to say that.
The,
I don't want to give them any publicity,
you know,
and I'm not going to be to hate what he's doing.
Okay.
What he's the owner is doing is just selling traffic and trying to like,
you know,
do scams and trying to get people to his website with scams.
He's not stealing any credit card information as far as I know he's doing stuff
that's like,
right.
All your shit.
Slightly sleazy.
You know,
I'm like tweets,
if he had your login somehow he probably could download it.
All your private messages.
Yeah.
But there might be.
It could be.
Yeah.
But there wasn't,
but um,
the,
the point is that I don't think what he's doing as a terrible thing,
but it just,
it was creepy.
It was creepy that all of a sudden some guy like makes a tweet from my Twitter
about some fucking contest.
And then,
you know,
it turns out that I had met this dude,
he had been to like a bunch of you fcs and they had pictures with me and he's
like made a little blog about it and that's when it got
really creepy cause you made it,
this little blog about it and then send me,
sent a tweet about it with my name in it in uh,
the title of this blog.
And I got the same tweet from no bullshit,
maybe 50 or 60 other Twitter sites.
So he has like all these fake Twitter accounts and all of these accounts.
When I would go to them,
they would have all the exact same tweets.
So he just has like,
just,
uh,
just swarming the Internet was spam and bullshit and then infecting your Twitter
and then tweeting from your Twitter and making you follow him.
So out of the hundred thousand people that were following him,
you know,
who knows how many of them voluntarily signed up for it?
Cause I know I fucking sure as fuck didn't nobody uses my Twitter except me.
I,
I don't,
no one even has the password except me.
No one's,
I don't have an assistant that does that Shit,
you know?
So when I know who I follow,
I wasn't following that guy and he was the last one I followed.
So it was like a recent thing and I looked at it and I was like,
this is nuts man.
This is what,
it's really nothing,
you know,
cause it's isn't,
there's no point
done.
It shows that,
that somehow he got into something exerts you could be in your email,
you can be in your,
which just shows the vulnerability of at least Twitter.
Right.
You know,
and you know,
of course people have done that on Facebook and then a bunch of other things and
you know,
it's,
it's a common thing on the Internet to misrepresent who you are.
You know?
I don't know.
It's,
uh,
it's just,
when you have information online,
you know,
and then they're putting it on servers and people are going to be able to get
it.
Man.
It's just,
they're just going to be able to get it.
You have to assume that the ultimate,
like the fight right now is everybody's trying to keep everybody else from
getting at their information,
getting out of their data,
getting it.
But the real truth is eventually there's going to be no secrets.
You're not going to be the w.
The idea of privacy is going to be out the window.
It's not going to exist anymore.
And essentially that's probably what's going to be the doom of the financial
system as well.
It'll be impossible to hold onto money.
There'll be,
it'll be impossible to,
it won't make any sense.
Everyone's going to have to access to everybody else's money.
You're just,
cause we don't steal from each other.
Right.
It's like the interconnectivity will eventually reach some sort of a boiling
point when if you look at what's,
what's what people are capable of doing now,
it's stealing credit card numbers and you know,
and and essentially getting at the ones and Zeros that you'll use to get by and
those ones and Zeros are all tallied and scored online.
Eventually people are going to get to a point where those don't mean anything.
They're going to get into those things and they're just gonna fuck the whole
system sideways and it won't be worth anything.
Yeah.
Well I've had my credit card stolen numbers stolen twice,
three times since I've lived in La.
Yeah.
I've had it stolen before to a gas station.
Gas Station.
Yeah.
And in waiters,
waiters will have little readers.
So when you pay for your bill,
they'll come in and just like scan your thing in.
They're in their apron and then give it back to yeah.
That was a weird feeling when I got it.
Oh,
from my accountants.
Are you buying $1,000 worth of chocolate?
Yeah.
That was like what they would,
they were buying shit.
I wish.
Well they were buying things that they could sell,
like they're buying.
Um,
like the gift cards.
Yeah.
And then,
you know,
hey man,
you want me to get a girl?
Feel good.
I've got a hundred dollar gift card,
Bro.
$20 notice I made him an urban character.
Yeah.
Why was that?
I Dunno.
I was going to go with Armenian,
but I wasn't confident with my,
my,
that sounds just so standard.
So formulaic.
I didn't want to go with that one.
So,
um,
uh,
in Canada,
Dave,
um,
this is our fucking big news.
All the experts,
a coalition of prominent BC police officer's health professionals,
leaguer experts,
academics and academics are calling for the legalization and regulated sale of
marijuana.
It's really kind of nuts,
man.
Dude,
come on man.
A coalition.
Listen to that.
Of police officers off of the roof.
That's
why.
Why do we,
why is gay associated with a list sometimes?
What does that cause it's usually have Cox,
Cox in her mouth.
Is that what it is?
Painful.
But how come girls don't get sloppy when they're sucking Dick all the time?
They don't start Lisbon.
If you'd imagine if that would like,
you found out that girls,
like if you talked to girls like y'alls girls,
Lisbon like crazy.
She been sucking dicks all weekend.
And when you suck decks,
like it feels good for the guy,
but I'm going to lift.
You're going to make me laugh baby.
It feels so good though.
I don't care.
I don't care about that list.
It doesn't,
it doesn't turn you off from nine lift.
Has a lot of guys have fed,
reminds them of all the of the Dick fell off packed.
Like if you have a bank of dicks you can only suck a certain amount and then
your lips just give out and your tongue gets all sloppy and you produce extra
saliva and it not only do you list be spit on people dudes,
it's still want their dick.
Sorry,
I don't care baby.
I don't care because a new doctor and he's going to glean your drain,
your salivary glands.
The bad news is you got to drink water every 30 seconds,
but the good news is you won't this pending and their teeth are all nicely
polished just for the front being rubbed against somebody talks.
Yeah,
they don't even really a brush.
It's Cox or and going and then pushing that all the food.
You know that's how the head of the Dick has designed these,
you know the head of the Dick is designed to actually like the reason why your
Dick is like pointing at the top and it has like that little bulging area that
like goes in and then the shaft comes out.
It's cause it's designed to push down into the woman's vagina and squirt all the
sperm up and then pull the sperm out.
That's what it's designed for.
If you like,
look at the way the head is,
you know,
see the head is like sort of like a helmet with the idea is that the way it's
shaped,
it would go in and whatever sperm was in there would actually get pressed up
against the Dick and forced up to the top where it was stored on this lip and
then you would pull it out and then you shoot your own in there.
Like what?
What does,
the whole idea of breeding is designed under the idea that someone had already
fucked her first.
For sure.
The whole design of the Dick is designed to just like,
we just get this,
get this out of the way.
Someone's fucked her.
Okay,
you gotta get that juice out and put your own in this,
the only one going have kids.
Fucking amazing.
It's really amazing when you stop and think about that.
There was a theory for a while but it was disproven where uh,
they were,
they were thinking that a certain amount of sperm were attacks berm.
I love this idea.
It was a great idea and I really wished it was evidence for it cause I would
have some material on it.
I could almost like ignore it just to do a bid on it but fuck,
I can't,
it's not true.
That,
and what they were saying was that a certain amount of sperm were actually
designed just to go in and attack and kill other sperm.
But it was like this one guy who had this theory and apparently a lot of other
people are like,
where's the fucking evidence for it?
It's like this is nuts.
This is like how do you,
how do you,
what?
What are they killing each other with?
They have bats,
you know,
he's killer scrub.
They just fucking cells.
It just loads.
You know what he talking about?
Loads that kill what bitch you reading some science fiction.
You know what?
I love the idea though.
One of my favorite things to do.
You ever take your ball skin and then wrap it around your boss and your Dick and
make a little like backwards bowling ball.
Have you ever done that?
One of my favorite things to do.
You said so if someone says,
Hey Brian,
no,
would you like to do ride a race car one?
No.
Like Dick Suck.
It freaks them out because they can't understand what's going on cause they
don't know balls that well.
And at that point they'll probably be like,
why am I here?
What have I done to deserve this guy in front of me pulling his ball skin over
his belly button?
And if you have a lot of hair,
they can't find the scene.
Amazing
backwards bullying Paul.
No,
I've never heard of that man.
Do it.
To go back to this,
um,
this illegalized BC thing,
one of the reason why they're,
uh,
thinking about legalizing marijuana is the results from Portugal apparently.
So Portugal,
they decriminalized all drugs,
drug use in 2001.
And the theory was that focusing on prevention and treatment rather than jailing
users would be the most beneficial way.
So Portugal try decriminalization and,
uh,
the use of possession of heroin,
cocaine,
marijuana,
LSD and other illicit drugs.
All those were decriminalized.
And five years later they found that the number of street drug overdoses dropped
from 400 to two 90 annually.
And the new number of HIV cases linked dropped from 1400 to about 400.
So a thousand less HIV cases and you know,
110 less,
um,
uh,
drug overdoses.
I mean that's a lot man.
You know,
and the dealings drugs is still illegal.
You still can't deal it,
but the users aren't jailed.
Instead they're putting in front of a panel that includes one lawyer or a judge
and a health or a social services worker.
And the panel can recommend treatment and,
or a small fine or no sanction at all.
So it's based on,
you know,
what kind of an impact you're having on society.
I mean,
you,
uh,
you do and drugs then breaking people's windows you'd do and drugs and shitting
in the street.
Well they might find you for shitting in the street cause someone's got to clean
that up.
But it's amazing that it's really,
it's,
it's shown that it's better to have these things legal and decriminalize and not
lock up the users.
So Canada is looking at this and they're going,
why the fuck are we in?
The reason why,
the number one reason why is America,
America wants candidate to keep their fucking laws exactly the same way that
constantly been pushing,
putting pressure on them.
It's just embarrassing.
It's getting to the point where it's embarrassing that marijuana,
it's embarrassing.
It is embarrassing.
It's ridiculous.
It's like no,
no other end people.
So it's just drug.
You know what he fucking drug him in.
You need a drug that's not even it.
Even if I never wanted to do marijuana again for the rest of my life,
I would still say that you telling me I can't do it as the most ridiculous thing
I've ever heard in my life.
It's like if you are living alone on an island and there was only four people on
the island and one of them said,
if you smoke weed,
I'm going to lock in jail.
The other three would be like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Dude,
we've got other shit to worry about.
Why do you care if I want to sit on the island and get high once I do my chores?
What do you give a fuck if I'm productive members so well that that one person
at a four is just as ridiculous as what we've got going on right now.
What we've got going on right now is some people and they're telling other
people what they can and can't do with their body.
It doesn't hurt a God damn thing.
And that's stupid.
And at least Canada's figuring that out first.
But they still deported that Mark Emery Guy,
the poor fucking guy,
man was living free in his own country and he was selling seeds,
seeds to a goddamn plant.
That makes you silly.
What are you going,
you got to go pee?
I'm going to talk about myself.
This is ridiculous.
You fucking weak bladder bitch,
by the way.
Um,
I will be playing the,
uh,
UFC drinking game this weekend,
this weekend.
Uh,
the UFC is in Vegas and it's a Bj Penn versus Nick Diaz.
Unfortunately,
George St Pierre was supposed to be fighting,
was supposed to be fighting Carlos condit and fucking amazing fight,
but it was really looking forward to,
it was the whole car.
It was kind of crazy.
It started out,
it was a,
Nick Diaz was supposed to be fighting George Saint Pierre and Nick Diaz kind of
flaked at a few press conferences and then they pulled them out and said,
all right,
Carlos Khan is now fighting GSP.
And everybody was like,
what?
And then they said,
Nick Diaz,
you still want to fight,
you got to fucking do press all this shit.
And he's like,
okay,
all right,
you're fighting Bj Penn.
And everybody's like,
Holy Shit.
Cause actually that made it even like that's pretty God damn exciting.
It was supposed to be GSP versus um,
uh,
be GSP versus condit,
which is an amazing fight.
GSP versus Diaz Rather,
And he got,
you know,
condit versus GM versus Bj Penn,
which is another amazing fight.
So they essentially just swapped and it was eagle then.
Unfortunately it was even rather,
but unfortunately GSP hurt his knee and he fell out.
He,
I think he had a,
a strain or a strained MCL and uh,
it's gonna be a couple of months.
It has to do rehab on it and shit and so really,
really big,
big disappointment.
But the rest of the card is still fucking sick.
There's a lot of,
a lot of good fights on this.
Joey's coming down with me and um,
Jamie Kilstein is coming up from New York.
I was bringing his little brother should be fun.
I'm looking forward to it.
I haven't been to Vegas in a long time either.
It's been a while.
It's supposed to,
to a Halloween party with that South Park.
Uh Oh real.
The people that work for south park or throwing a party and
I don't know what to go as it cause everyone that goes there.
I went last year and the year before and every time they go there,
they,
everyone goes overboard.
Like everyone's like spending months on their costumes.
You know you should be the exploding desk squad cat,
but yeah,
but what am I going?
Where am I going to get that and get a cat outfit and some fucking fix that good
idea.
Strap yourself together.
Get a watch.
Like a flavor flav clock.
Oh,
that's a good idea.
We started with a thought,
don't go with a Hitler mustache.
She got to get rid of iTunes.
Where you should take that off the,
yeah,
just take that off anyway.
It's stupid.
Why?
Given that stupid cat a Hitler,
Hitler's chaplain.
Chaplain.
It's Hitler because Hitler is after chaplain every everyone else.
It's a mental test to see if you're a Hitler chaplain and it just to see your
personality.
It's a personality test.
Have a little,
or it could be Michael Jordan because he pulled it exactly.
It's to Jordan,
but that's a goofy move on Michael Jordan.
How big is his ego?
Yeah,
Hitler mustache.
I got the Kingsborough cat too,
bro.
I got the kick ass girl costume,
but I think it's,
it's too tight because it's a girl's extra large girl,
but that's only like a 32 waist,
like gut hangs out of it.
It's hard.
It's actually pretty funny looking.
I don't know if I want to embarrass myself because that's embarrassing.
You know when you have like a super tight and you're dressed up as a girl at the
same time,
well you're supposed to be funny,
right?
I guess you gotta be careful though.
You're going to,
are you going to hang out with your girl?
Yeah.
You don't want to be too humiliating.
Exactly.
So the other thing is she's going to go is when would be cool,
sexy,
windy,
sexy Wendy from the hamburger place.
Yes.
I'm going to be,
I'm a Zombie.
She goes,
he's dead.
Okay.
I was going to say she goes a cow with a bullet hole.
Yeah.
Can do that too.
I was going to be Dave Thomas,
but it's like decaying.
He still has a little tie on and stuff,
but you don't have to shave your beard.
I know.
It won't take two weeks,
two weeks to go back.
That's not a bad one.
If she got a theme thing going on,
but then you know,
you've kind of be in the Beta to your,
your chick's lead,
you know,
you're following her lead.
You know,
maybe it could be a wolf that,
that the big bad wolf that catches Wendy in the woods.
Or it could be Ronald,
you'd be aware of wolf catches her on the way home.
Is there a bringing bonds back and just give her the Dick in the bushes?
Is there a tee?
Somebody said that there's a TV show from the 80s.
I was about werewolves that Joe Rogan was a character in,
in the,
the name Joe Rogan was a character.
Yeah.
Come on.
Probably some nonsense from Wikipedia.
I didn't check.
So they had a god damn,
uh,
some website.
I won't even give them the dignity of naming the website.
Had a list of a werewolf movies,
the best werewolf movies ever.
My God.
Is it a piece of shit list?
First of all,
they had this,
they didn't have the howling on,
which is a goddamn Travis to,
you got to have the howling if you're going to have werewolf movies.
There's really only two.
There's American Werewolf in London and the howling,
those are the only two good ones.
American Werewolf in London being far superior.
That's the greatest werewolf movie of all time for sure.
But they have like ginger snaps,
which I saw,
which was the werewolf was so bad.
It looked like someone drew a scary face on a balloon werewolf.
A TV series for the 1987 to 1988 the character's name was Alamo Joe Rogan.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
That is weird man.
Wasn't Alamo Joe Rogan a fucking baseball player.
Wasn't that like a famous black baseball player or there was like no rocket Joe
Rogan or some point that Joe Rogan.
Joe Rogan baseball player.
Yeah.
Famous black baseball player.
But what it was is he had like a nickname though.
It was like hurricane something or hold stick just right.
Uh,
Joe Rogan.
Baseball player.
Yeah,
their asshole.
Don't write that but cool.
Don't worry about all the bullet.
Yeah.
Bullet Joe Rogan.
He was in the Negro League.
Isn't that crazy?
See the resemblance.
It's a lot like me.
She just,
we just had a failure.
We have a mic,
arm failure and choked down.
Hey.
Oh,
where'd it go?
It just gave up.
We don't use the best components here at the Joe Rogan experience podcast.
Let me fit this spring back.
All right.
Turn down your mic real quick.
So why do you do that?
Uh,
we owe,
this is how I guess we can say it's a death squad as a comedy show.
Uh,
tomorrow at the Ice House we have Duncan Trussell,
uh,
is going to be there with little Hobo.
Our Magical Stephen is easy from the league.
Uh,
Kevin Christie,
and it's same Tripoli's birthday tomorrow.
So we're having a huge party.
We're just going to get drunk and wasted and Jason Tubo is going to drive us
all.
Uh,
so that's tomorrow at the Ice House.
Eight and 10 o'clock.
You got to icehouse website.
You can buy tickets now.
Last week it sold out.
We had Joe Rogan there and we're also going to be recording a,
another,
a podcast there,
uh,
with Dunkin and,
and so that's going to be interesting.
Uh,
Joe still fixing them?
Mike arm.
I think we're back.
All right.
Sorry.
Yeah,
I got to get some better mind.
Go arms.
I liked that.
I liked the old ones.
We had better actually.
I've been watching the guests use it.
It's not an arm,
it's just kind of like a pacing.
That noise.
Um,
the best way is really to have them stationary and you just make the guy come up
to it.
Yeah.
You know,
Corolla has it set up where he's got,
um,
a straight arm and it's screwed into the table.
There's a straight arm.
You can move it left or right,
but that's it.
Right.
That's really the best.
This,
this fucking thing is moving around.
Too much content on it.
But it's back.
But this seems so cool to have this mechanical arm it cause it seems like we're
professionals.
We're playing,
we're playing radio,
radio.
Well we're on the radio.
Legit now if you don't know,
we're on Sirius satellite radio.
I don't know what channel it is.
Opie and Anthony Channel used to be two a two I think or something like that.
The buyer's opie and Anthony Channel now it's really not the virus anymore.
They finally wised up.
I mean ob open the Anthony's a fucking huge radio station or a huge radio,
a shell.
And they had been calling it the virus since the beginning for like,
what has it been like eight years or something crazy.
How long have you been on serious?
Long time.
I was serious.
What's sent me a free subscription.
At least they don't even give you shit.
I don't give me that.
Don't care.
Nothing.
You don't get a God damn thing.
Did you hear them talk about Patrice the other day on Opie and Anthony?
I didn't hear it,
but I heard about it through the Internet.
Uh,
from the board as sad.
Yeah.
Subvert or actually tweeted me about.
I was like,
wow.
Then I went and looked online and he had a stroke.
You know,
we,
we talk about it all the time,
you know,
cause it's a,
it's a big thing in my head.
You kind of take care of your fucking shell.
You've got to take care of your body.
You have to,
you gotta,
you know,
you could fuck around a little bit,
but God dammit,
overall you should really be kind of fit.
You should do your best to be kind of fit.
You'll have a better life.
You're really well.
If you eat healthy,
take care of yourself,
you'll have a better life.
But Theresa is always a big guy and he also had a lot of health problems too.
He had diabetes,
which is just fucking,
just a huge drag,
you know?
And that,
I don't know what contributes to a stroke that could have easily contributed to
it.
And some people that are real healthy get die,
get strokes.
You know,
strokes.
Father had a stroke when he was 67 he smoked every day and I struck at 67 and
then he had like a couple heart attacks 10 years later.
But the stroke made him be like eight normal guy to being with a cane.
He had to learn,
relearn how to walk again.
I nanny ever since he had that stroke was pretty miserable.
That's all I remember him being just bored and miserable.
Well I would imagine,
you know,
your shell becomes a prison,
you can't,
you can't fucking get around.
That's,
that's a drag man.
But there you are smoking,
smoking,
you know,
you know I'm more concerned about is my mom's been getting crazy.
My mom gets moles removed all the time cause they're cancerous moles.
Oh God.
And they found one the other day and they're like,
this is really bad.
This is like,
we caught it early but this is like,
this is cancerous and it's like near your or spine or something weird like that.
And it's,
and the crazy thing is,
it's like,
they're like,
all right,
so we're gonna schedule you,
you know,
December 14th to take it out.
And I'm like,
wait a second,
you just said it was cancer.
Shouldn't you get that out?
Like now?
Like who cares if it's a slow growing cancer immediately,
especially because you know you have cancer now you're freaking out.
Who knows if that's going to accelerate the growth of the thing.
I think it's probably a scheduling issue that probably,
you know,
an insurance issue and a bunch of other different things.
But yeah,
a better,
she had a lot of money,
they'd probably get around immediately.
And my sister,
it's just got some moles removed for cancer and,
and now I'm like,
wait,
I haven't been to the doctor ever.
And I got,
I shave.
I know.
I just,
I you just go all the time.
I'm not,
I hate doctors.
I don't have a family doctor anymore.
Our family dentist,
I grew up with like the same doctor my whole life and then I just moved away and
now I just go to like urgent cares,
you know,
I don't want to have a relationship with a doctor and too old for that.
Now when are you going back to Ohio again?
Yeah,
exactly.
What is UFC coming here to hemo.
You could,
um,
schedule it,
you know,
and the next time he done.
That's true.
Since you liked the guy,
as long as you're gonna to go here.
And you know,
I noticed also,
I talked about this always on Thompson as podcasts.
We always talk,
have a dental update every week.
But I,
I noticed that dentists out here also seem more like car car salesman.
Like they,
they're automatically trying to get you to upgrade things when he'd go there.
Like the other day I went to the dentist and they,
they,
they charged me for a fluoride treatment.
I'm like,
I just wanted to cleaning.
What's this fluoride treatment?
And she's like,
oh,
she didn't go through.
That's extra.
You know,
you can get it.
And I'm like,
no,
she just gave it to me and I didn't ask for a fluoride,
but they were trying to add things on like Monday,
you know,
like,
oh,
you got the extra warranty,
tried to sell me on braces,
braces,
bitch.
You know,
my front seats are straight,
but two,
that would be fucking awesome.
Can we get braces?
Get the metal on my front teeth are perfect,
but my bottom teeth,
there's some bunching up,
pretty bad ass.
But he said it to me and I looked at it a,
I'm,
I go,
I'm a man.
I don't give a fuck of my teeth are a little,
can I chew through me?
Right.
Yeah,
they're good.
Well,
it's not like they're all jacked.
No,
because they don't know.
You don't want to be like that old person with the wing.
You don't feel,
you don't get extra teeth coming in and it gets spread out more.
When a frank shamrock got braces,
the former UFC champion and he needed braces,
he had some weird dental thing going on where you had like double teeth.
Right.
You ever met people that have like teeth that grow over teeth.
They're like a lot of weird shit going on.
Right.
So I don't,
I don't know what that's about,
but he needed braces,
if that makes sense.
Like I understand like you don't want people to let go every time you smiled.
What the fuck is going on as well?
You know there's certain,
you know,
you start tweaking about extra teeth and shit starts fucking with your head.
You're like,
I don't want to get rid of some of these goddamn teeth and fix my face.
That makes sense.
But to just have a little bit of a crooked tooth here and they're like,
come on bitch,
what are you worried about?
I never understood why there's like you see those older people or whatever that
has that one funky tooth that shoots out of their mouth and they were just like,
why don't you just at least get that polled?
You know you're,
you're just holding onto like,
you know,
like bald people are holding onto that and the last amount of hair and trying to
comb it over,
move it around the circle with a fuck.
If you get that shit,
take it.
There's right writer took all his teeth out.
Oh God.
All of his teeth.
He just drank.
I think I've talked about this before.
He always drinks like mountain dew.
Like you drink like a 12 pack of mountain dew a day and his teeth were so bad he
never went to the dentist cause you're gonna you know,
whatever for whatever reason.
And they were like,
dude,
all your teeth are fucked.
And he's like,
ah,
just pull them all.
Oh my God.
Pull them all.
It would cause the food.
Well,
he has fake teeth now like ventures,
but you know it's like the,
the cost to fix it all was impossible.
You know.
Oh my God,
like $20,000 something like Oh my God.
So,
so he has like basically like the whole denture thing,
like a plastic gum and you stick it on with glue.
Like they have like the Polident shit.
You ever see those commercials were like,
look,
your dentures can stay even under water and they'd take a glass and they blew
the fucking fake teeth to it and they put it under water.
Drink your water and not worried about your two falling out.
That's so dark man.
When you,
when you have your whole mouth full of fake teeth,
that's dark.
Yeah.
I had a friend who had no teeth.
My friend Mal Vernon,
Tommy,
he had no fucking teeth for Vernon.
Tom Over at Tommy.
Yeah.
He was a pool hustler from white plains for,
for Mount Vernon.
But you know,
he used to come by executive billiards in white plains new year.
The a certain weird dog and the need,
you didn't them any teeth.
He had no teeth when he wanted a good little Philemon Yoan.
And what I do is I put it in the blender,
puts a Philemon yawn in the blender so that he could just fucking buzz it down
and then eat it.
Sort of like how I make my smoothie with Kale and shit.
He would do that with steak.
He would buzz up steak in a blender and then eat them like this poor fuck he's
got no goddamn teeth.
Yeah,
it was,
he had,
I met some crazy fucking people in my pool hall days,
but he was one of the craziest,
really nice guy.
Great Pool Player,
but terrible organizer of his life.
And what he did was he would work for a taxi dispatch and a,
he would work like ridiculous,
ridiculous hours,
get enough money together and then go play pool with it.
And gamble is money.
I mean he has a guy that was probably only making a few hundred bucks a week.
Right.
And he would,
you know,
regularly come in and you know,
gamble for a couple thousand bucks and sometimes he would lose and when he would
lose,
then he would go into debt with what's called a Shylock and want a Shylock is,
is uh,
essentially a gangster,
a,
a person who loans you money and they learn you loan you cash when you
ordinarily can't get alone and they do it at a ridiculous rates of interest and
you know,
you have to play pay points and he would fucking,
he would go into debt with these guys,
owe them like fucking,
you know,
20 grand,
10 grand,
whatever the fuck it is.
And this poor guy would just disappear for months and just work it off,
just disappear and then go right back into the hole again.
Same thing,
come gum back and,
and get alone and [inaudible] to get alone and play some,
a lot of people talking a little shit,
I'm going to come back and play some,
show him how to fucking do it.
You know,
they don't have good cue ball control and he would like tell you why he was
going to win and control.
You knew,
you knew the chances are that he's probably going to lose.
It was going to be the same fucking thing over and over again eventually.
You know,
it's like you,
you're,
you're running,
you're always,
always behind.
You know,
the expression always behind the eight ball.
It just fucking can't quite catch a break.
And I watched this guy and I learned a lot.
You know,
you learn a lot from people that are out of control in their life about what's
possible.
Like the justifications,
you know,
like when you see people addicted to gambling or addicted to anything,
you can,
you can watch people with their control of life slips away.
And it's fascinating to watch.
You know,
I never been around gamblers until I started playing pool.
Do you know anybody that's a gambler?
I know card players and it's kind of sad and depressing because it's all about
luck,
you know?
And then sometimes they're like on top of the game and then other times you,
you just see them like are suffering.
Like they're fucking selling shit and just,
well it's certainly not totally about luck,
but luck plays a in that.
Yeah,
for the most part it plays a part.
You definitely,
when you have guys have equal skill,
then yeah,
luck certainly plays a part when the game was at uno,
so it was mostly water
hooked on,
you know,
I'm like,
what?
Because Ari is a pretty successful at poker and he does it through strategy and
his intellect and his discipline.
He's,
he's a good poker player,
man.
He makes money.
There was a lot of times where he's making way more money playing poker than he
was doing comedy,
but I think that shit's kinda dried up to,
I think it's hard.
The Internet apparently just festered infested with bots.
There was a guy who was a on one of these a pool websites and he's a pretty
pretty knowledgeable dude and he was talking about how it's useless to play
poker on these websites because they're all there.
They're like,
when you get on a website,
you might be playing in a room with five people,
but two of them might be bots and that might,
they might be bots set forward by the,
um,
the,
the poker company and you can't beat them.
And they're,
they're computer programs.
They're running,
it's cheating,
you're cheating.
And they're essentially running up the bents and making people bet more money
and Boston people.
And it's like,
maybe it could just be you and some of the guy who doesn't know how to play
poker and you could make some fucking money,
but no,
no,
no.
It's you and some other guy who doesn't know how to play poker and bots.
You're not going to win fucking crazy man.
When you hear about shit like that.
And then those,
uh,
which guys got busted recently,
they've gotten a lot of big,
big trouble.
They,
oh Bruce.
Buffer money.
And there was a bunch of your time.
We'll all start put,
what is it?
The one that's always on people's backs,
right?
And what the fuck is it called?
Fuck what's which,
which do search poker scandal.
Full tilt,
full tilt poker.
Yeah.
Apparently these guys just,
they had a bunch of money that they kept their like in a bank and these
motherfuckers are spent it.
They just,
they ripped off online players to the tune of 444 million bucks.
Holy Shit.
That's amazing.
And these guys,
well there were poker players there.
This is who started it,
the Department of Justice specifically named pros,
Howard Lederer and Chris Ferguson who were the founders of the site back in 2004
in the scheme,
uh,
the amount of poker pros who are involved with full tilt is hard to ignore.
So they don't know really how many people were involved.
But these guys,
uh,
they,
they just made mad loot stealing from people.
That's how the world of the Gambler,
the pool player,
poker player,
like the,
the,
the dice player people,
the world of the Gambler,
w just to the cold war with CD people to try to make this legitimate like what
they're trying to do now with all this crazy,
you know,
professional poker and shit that didn't exist when I was in high school.
What,
what this is,
is like they're doing,
as they're cleaning up degenerates,
they're cleaning up,
degenerates and presenting them to the American public.
But these are degenerates.
Even if they're,
they're really rich and successful and at it,
at their core,
they're,
most of them were degenerate gamblers.
And those are,
those people are crazy.
Those people did not.
He Shit,
man.
There's a certain percentage of them that are off their fucking rocker.
That's why they've wound up as professional gamblers.
You know,
they're,
they're junkies for adrenaline and craziness and their impulse people and are
people that are willing to take ridiculous chances.
You know,
there's,
there's a lot of nuttiness to the world of the professional gambler.
I've never been a gambler.
I never had that in me at all.
I can't,
I don't like making bets.
And once in a while in Vegas,
I'll do it.
Like I'll,
I'll,
I'll just,
cause I not,
I don't get to do that ever unless I'm in Vegas.
So once in a while I would spend like,
you know,
like 100 bucks Max,
but not really.
It's a scary,
you never going to win.
You mean what?
You went a little bit here and there,
but God damn you can lose a fuckload.
Yeah,
the pool players fuck themselves.
When it came to gambling,
they uh,
there was only one time that the casino put a line on a pool tournament.
It was the US Open.
And you know,
when a a casino puts a line on a pool tournament,
uh,
essentially they're saying this guy's the favorite.
This guy's the big underdog.
And the big underdog was like,
you know,
40 to one or where the fuck it was was Mike Lebron and Mike Bronze.
A good player.
But he's not like the best players like Earl Strickland,
Johnny Archer,
those are,
those are the guys that everybody assumed were probably Mike Segal.
Those are the guys.
Everybody assumed we're going to get to the top buddy hall.
Those are like the real names.
Well,
they all dumped to this Michael Lebron guy.
They all went,
they all went to the fucking,
the gambling booth.
They bet all their money on Michael Lebron to win.
And then everybody lost him.
Mike,
Lebron,
and they all went cleaned up and then the,
the casino was like,
you mother fuckers like you,
you fucking,
but,
and you know,
what can they say?
I mean you,
you,
you can't leave a cat in a room with a mouse and expect him not to kill it.
It's just the way it is.
They're,
they're degenerates.
The things you can help it to them first place,
you know,
at a good pool tournament and Seton home.
Back then it might've been like seven grand.
It might've been like,
if it was a big tournament and my us open,
it's like 40 or 50 back.
Who knows?
If it was 20 or 30 whatever it was,
$30,000 is a big score,
but you're not short of winning.
If you're going up,
you're playing a pool tournament.
It's a double elimination tournament.
You lose once to Johnny Archer and then another time to Earl Strickland.
You're out.
You can do that or you just put all your money.
I'm like Lebron and everybody gets together and say,
let's make a deal.
I'm not going to button.
I bet a dollar make 40 isn't hard to fucking figure out folks.
It's pull our money.
We've got 1000 bucks,
we're going to make $42,000 right now.
Split that shit up.
No,
no,
no drama whatsoever.
Let's do it.
And so they all got together and everybody bet on this guy.
And then the casinos never gambled on pool again.
They were like,
well,
we're not stupid.
You know,
it's not like you can't,
it's not like basketball.
Whereas like you know,
there's a lot of money and winning.
It's not like boxing.
I don't know if there's any fighters that are going to put money down on
themselves and then take a dive.
Maybe they would if it was the end of their career and they can be assured that
they can make a lot of money.
That was always a big speculation about Marvin because Marvin Hagler lost his
last fight to sugar ray Leonard,
where he was a big favorite to win that fight and it didn't look like the same.
Marvin Hagler.
It didn't look like,
like when he got sugary against the ropes,
didn't look like it was really punishing them.
It didn't really look like he was trying to stop him.
It was almost like he knew that the fix was in and he was a part of it because
after it was over,
I mean,
and I'm just,
look,
Marvin Hagler is one of the greatest boxers of all time.
I'm not implying,
I'm just going with the urban legend.
After it was over,
he leaves and goes to Italy and makes movies.
He becomes an Italian movie star just leaves.
So like if he made some sort of a deal with the mob
and they're like,
listen,
this is what I'm gonna do.
I'm going to bet a lot of money on a sugar ray Leonard.
You will knock,
knock 'em out and you leave them alone.
The judges are in the bucket to going to make a lot of money.
Come to Italy.
[inaudible] star.
Fuck this box saying you want to be a movie star in Italy.
So they taught them Italian,
flew him out to Italy.
He would give him a fucking movie star.
It's that's those,
the urban,
that's the urban legend.
The reality is one of the greatest boxers of all time.
Marvin Hagler,
huge Marvin Hagler Fan.
He was a monster man.
I remember when I was a kid,
I watched him,
he was training from a staff of ham show and they had him on the news cause he
was,
he was,
what he would do is on the Cape,
he would live on Cape Cod,
which is the ocean that nobody went to in the winter.
God was fucking frigid,
you know,
it's zero degrees and the waves would be crashing and the wind would be whipping
in the fucking windshield factor was like,
who knows how many fucking degrees below zero and this motherfucker would be
running on the beach screaming war.
You know Marvin Hagler like I remember watching it on TV when I was a little kid
going,
Holy Shit,
look at this guy.
Like that was in my mind,
like that's what a fighter could be.
Like.
The scariest fighter would be a fighter that's doing everything correctly.
100% focus,
100% dedicated,
stays away from his wife,
doesn't go anywhere near as kids,
locks himself in a fucking house on the beach and just works out every day and
runs on the beach and just wants to kill you and can't wait.
And it's counting the days down for he gets to punch you in the fucking face,
you know?
So I'm not saying that Marvin Hagler took a dive,
but I'm saying that that's the rumor.
This is going to be a fun UFC man.
You gotta start,
when's the next year?
I've said you're going to come to,
you want to come to San Jose?
San Jose.
We've got some shows there too.
We're doing a,
when is that?
During the San Jose Improv.
When is that?
Do you know what number?
Uh,
cause it on my little calendar,
I guess November 18th,
we're going to be at the San Jose and Improv.
It's a Joey Diaz is coming now.
We just found out that Brian is coming as well.
I Dunno who else to come in.
We might have one other comic con,
maybe Dunkin or whoever's around.
And,
uh,
then we got the,
the two shows at the,
um,
at the San Jose Improv that night.
And then the UFC is the next night and it's a,
it's a killer.
UFC too.
It's Vandelay Silva versus Conley and Shogun versus Henderson.
It's got a nice fucking nuts.
That's a good one.
God,
I hope nobody gets hurt before that one comes.
I get right.
It kind of sucks.
That was sports crazy.
You know,
when you're,
when you got to practice kicking the shit out of each other and punching each
other and need each other in the face and Shit,
man,
people get hurt.
You know,
you tweaked knees.
Look,
even George Saint Pierre,
man George has never pulled out with a knee injury before.
I mean,
I think he's hurt himself in the past.
I can't remember him pulling out a fight cell because he was hurt.
Maybe I'm wrong.
I know he,
uh,
he,
he has been injured like after he fought Tiago Alvarez.
He,
he was laid up for a while because he fucked as growing up in that fight.
But I can't remember other injuries where he had to pull out of a fight.
I might be wrong though.
So many guys do.
It's just no way around it man.
And I hate it.
But it's a smart thing to do.
You got to pull out,
you can't fight injured,
you know you fight injured,
you get fucked up,
you fight Carlos condit and you only got one wing do.
You might get jacked.
That guy's a beast if you can barely,
you know you can't move right.
And if you get hurts,
if it gets hurt more like during the fight and you like try to dig in on it and
move a certain direction,
maybe you can't move and you get hit with a kick you would've never got hit with
and then it's lights out and then your whole career changes.
Your whole life changes.
Like at that level of the game you can't do it.
But I seen dudes fight hurt before Mike [inaudible] was the biggest example.
He's a real tough guy.
And he came into the UFC once,
he fought a CBD Holloway and he came in with his whole leg taped up like a cast.
It was fucking nuts.
Like Soccer Raba style.
Have you ever saw Sakuraba back in the old pride days?
Sakharova was amazing fighter,
but his knees were fucked up.
He just had been leg locked too many times and kick too many times.
They were just badly damaged so bad that he would get these,
his legs taped up before the fights and it was nuts.
It was like a mummy.
I mean it was like he was like from halfway down to is the the to his calf all
the way up to like a foot above his knee.
It was all taped up.
It was like crazy.
But he had to do that and he would like walk like an old man,
you know,
you had to do that and then you'd go in and kick you with that same leg.
Fucking he like stabilize his own knees with tape and raps because it was like
old loose and fucked up.
You know,
it was really one of the reasons why people loved him.
They knew he's all battered up and he was still going there and go fucking
crazy.
But it's really not smart.
It's really not smart to fight injury,
you know?
And you're supposed to,
if you like,
you look at a guy like George Saint Pierre,
he does everything perfectly.
It's very technical and he wants to always be able to,
you know,
avoid getting hit but hit the other guy.
He wants to always be able to utilize the right strategy.
And if you got a fucked up wheel man,
if your knee is jack,
that's like,
that's a good percent of his whole game.
So game is about exploding on people and getting out of the way of people and
making sure people can't take them down and making sure he can take them down
and then kicking them.
You know,
there's,
that's his whole game kicking and punching him and taking him down and like,
fuck you can't kick somebody.
You can't,
you can't run out of the way.
you know?
That's a terrifying thing for a fighter to have.
Only one need at works.
What a fucking Dudee sport,
dude.
You take your body and you try to blast someone else's body with it.
No thanks.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
You get exhausted,
you know,
and everybody's just trying to figure out the right way to do it and no one's
quite got it mastered yet.
They've only got it mastered against this level and we're always looking at the
next level coming up.
Like even though Anderson Silva is,
no doubt about it,
the greatest fighter that ever walked the face of the earth,
there's nobody that's ever been better.
No one has ever done the kind of shit that that guy does.
I'll give you look at his fight,
his last fight that he had.
Man,
you should know Cami is a beast.
He's a tough,
tough fucking guy.
No one's ever handled him the way Anderson handled him.
Anderson is just on this complete total different new level.
But to some people coming up,
man,
they're coming up and they're,
they're going to be better.
There's the John Jones is of the world.
You know,
you look at John Jones go,
what's John Jones going to be like when he's 30 John Johnson's like 23 years old
dude,
and he's way better at 23 then he was at 22 I met him at 22 he was good then.
He's fucking way better now.
What's going to be like and he's 25 what's eating?
Even like when he's 28 years old,
he's going to be a fucking comic book Superhero Dude.
He's just going to be doing shit to people.
You can't even believe some young guy,
people that are coming up that aren't that talented.
People that have physical flaws,
people that have flaws and their game,
he's just going to run through them.
Just gonna run through them.
The question is,
when does the,
the two paths cross like the master,
like Anderson Silva,
who's a master at a certain few levels of the game and then this young kid
coming up who slowly mastering everything,
you know,
comes from this completely different discipline of wrestling.
You know,
Anderson comes from this Moitai discipline.
His,
his discipline is all about kicking you and punching and all of sudden there's
this wrestler who's kicking and punching you and he's like,
what?
He can wrestle too.
And he's developing this ridiculous kicking and punching game.
Fuck,
that's the next level.
And then there's going to be someone after him,
man.
There's to be some guy who does everything twice as fast as everybody else does
it.
And he's coming up right now.
He's probably 10 years old right now.
And what's holding the pads for him?
It was probably more fighters now in training than there's ever been ever been
by far.
And it's,
the organizations are growing,
you know,
people always say that the UFC is a,
um,
is a,
a monopoly,
you know,
and the,
they're,
they're actually even being investigated by someone from federal,
federal,
cc,
federal trade,
FTC federal trade commission,
and they're being investigated as being a monopoly,
but it's not a monopoly.
They just do it better than anybody else.
It's like you can't,
you can't say that Nascar is a monopoly,
but if you wanted to say,
hey,
let's start up our own fucking car league.
You know we're going to just race cars all across the country.
What are you going to call it?
The new car league.
Everybody like,
but it's not Nascar,
right?
No.
Well now it's not.
Nascar has a monopoly.
Just they're the best at it.
You could start your own car league if you want to.
That's the same thing with the UFC.
The UFC is not a monopoly.
You know,
they just have the best fighters right now cause they have the most money and
the most popularity,
but they built this shit up man.
If you want to do it by yourself,
do it by herself and Bella tours doing it by themselves.
There's a company called [inaudible].
They're fucking,
they've got some good fighters,
man.
They've got a good show.
They got this Guy Jimmy Smith who does the commentary.
He's really good at it.
He's a black belt in Jujitsu,
knows what the fuck is going on.
He's gives excellent commentary there.
Color guys,
really good.
They have a good show.
They do a different format where they have tournament's and they hold this
tournament and the tournament takes place over several weeks or several months
rather.
And then they pick a guy who wins a tournament and he fights for the title and
you know,
they do a fucking real good job man.
And they do a real good job with it and they just got bought out by Viacom.
So it's not that the UFC is a monopoly,
there's other people in the game.
They just been in the game longer.
They spent more money,
they invested more time,
they do it better.
It's that simple.
You know,
it's like there's a certain amount of people that whenever you get to a certain
level of success,
they want to,
they want to think that you did something wrong to get there.
But if it wasn't for the UFC,
man,
nobody would have invested that kind of money.
Eventually.
I think MMA would have slowly broken through to the mainstream over the course
of who knows how many years.
Or it could have wound up like soccer where everybody thought it was going to
make it,
but it never,
did you remember?
Well,
soccer when we were kids,
they're pushing soccer.
Like soccer is eventually going to be a big professional sport.
I remember that,
but it never did.
It just never quite marketed it correctly.
It never quite got through.
Yeah,
and same with hockey for Columbus.
He's still pretty good for Ohio at four I lived,
they tried to push hockey a lot.
Yeah,
it was pretty big for a while,
but now it's kind of like,
I don't think it's,
if someone smart,
if someone's got balls,
listen to me right now.
This is the thing.
K One kickboxing.
Kickboxing is some of the most exciting shit to watch in the world.
If you watch the highest level kickboxers God damn is that should exciting.
It's so fucking fun to watch.
They go at it,
man.
It's only three rounds.
Even title fights are like three rounds.
They fucking go to a war man.
And those,
some of the fights are five rounds I think.
But either way they,
they're,
they're fun and it's all striking,
which is what a lot of people like a lot of people don't like the wrestling
aspect of MMA.
I love it because I think it's the most realistic sport in the world.
I mean it is real fighting.
It's a sport of real fighting encompassing all the different techniques.
So to me it's more complicated.
It's more cerebral.
There's more strategy involved because there's more variables.
I,
I'm always going to be a huge fan of primarily of MMA.
If I had one thing to watch it would be MMA,
but I love fucking kickboxing too.
I love watching it.
It's so much more exciting than regular boxing and we know how boxing is still
doing well.
People still want to see a good boxing match.
You know,
if Manny Pacquiao was fighting,
people are still going to pack in to see that guy light people up.
But man,
if you watch some high level kickboxing,
boxing becomes boring because they can't kick,
they're not doing all this other crazy shit.
You Watch.
Like I went to the um,
morning time professional league.
They had a show at long beach and I went down and check that shit out.
God Damn,
it was fun,
Dude.
There was some of the best kickboxers in the world and just I was in the front
row and watching these guys go at it,
man.
Why Old Wild Shit?
Because they don't have to worry about being taken down.
There's no takedowns so they're just fucking t and off on each other.
Mad Wild head kick knockouts and spinning back fist knockouts and cotton people
with elbows.
It was nuts,
man.
It's a,
it's a crazy sport.
I can't believe that.
It doesn't get the press that it deserves because like maybe it's not as good as
MMA,
but God damn if it ain't a close second and it's not being promoted,
someone's,
someone's completely dropped the ball,
you know,
they owe the people own k one they owe a lot of money,
man.
They want to start fights,
but they want to not have to pay all the fighters that they owe money to and
they,
oh,
just fucking untold millions of dollars to fighters if they haven't paid.
So they're in a bad financial situation,
but it's because they're just,
they've didn't promote it correctly.
If somebody liked the UFC,
came along,
if zoo for came along and picked up k one,
they're not interested in it.
I've talked to them about it.
But if someone like that did,
if Mark Cuban did or someone with balls and a lot of money,
who loves the sport?
God Damn,
that's a gold mine.
It's a Goddamn gold mine.
Mark Cuban.
Go do it.
You already got Michael Chavela working for you.
Michael Chevelle,
the Australian guy and my buddy.
You've toned out.
You've completely zoned out.
Which talking about finding,
what are you doing?
You're online.
You're checking your Facebook.
No,
I was looking at trying to find something on Monday to talk about,
but I can't find it.
What was it?
Uh,
the,
I don't want to talk about it.
You don't want it because I want to find it.
If I talk about it cause it's kind of pointless.
Well,
why don't you help me tell me and I'll help you.
Oh,
there's a,
something about the anonymous,
uh,
it's a anonymous website that I wanted to do show you,
but,
and an anonymous website they have.
Yeah.
No,
I don't know if it's them or not.
I can't tell if it's real or not,
but it's pointless not mine.
So dare you Brian Up Darren.
So,
um,
this weekend,
Friday,
today's Thursday,
tomorrow night you got to show at the Ice House and when will the uh,
ice,
the ice house podcast studios confirmed,
right?
Yeah,
I live in the next week or two.
So I'm leaving all deaf squad over there and then we're still going to do a
podcast tomorrow though with Duncan Trussell.
Okay,
beautiful.
Yeah.
And uh,
you're going to do a podcast from the ice house and are you going to have it set
up with Mike?
So we're going to do it like old school,
like we did hold still and then once we get the studio there,
then we're probably going to make that a whole like night at the ice house or
something like that.
Well,
people were saying that the last one was good,
but it felt like I was pocket calling everybody.
Like that's what it was like.
It was like they're tuned into a conversation that you can barely hear.
You could hear everything else in the background and people really liked the
fact that we were sitting there at a desk right in front of the door to the
club.
People were getting a kick out of that,
like as the show was going on,
like people who are podcast fans like holy shit,
they're podcasting right there.
And it was really kind of cool,
you know?
Yeah.
If we had that area,
I would like to have eventually a,
an area set up where we could do it like maybe before the shows and in between
shows and doing the back room and the while the show's going on.
We could do it right there,
do it right there,
that table.
But we
would have to have it a little more soundproof than it is just a wee bit,
you know,
just like a curtain or something like that.
It would be cool if people knew we were right there.
But if,
if you hear it,
it's,
it's all the talking and shit.
It's like a really bleeds into the microphone.
It makes it hard to listen to.
They were talking about eventually I,
there's another office that depending on how all this goes,
how they were thinking about building a like a window so we could actually watch
who's on stage while we're podcasting behind the audience and then we can have
like little inner if so we can hear it would be amazing.
And you know what else we can do that I think we should probably fuck around
with a little bit is occasionally have shows live on stage,
have a podcast,
live on stage a Jim Norton.
Yeah,
because it's a small room because it's only 85 seats.
It's so intimate that it doesn't feel like the conversation is completely out of
line.
I just think that it,
exactly how it felt last time and though even if there's like a couple of
strangers in the room,
we were kind of not being ourself.
We're kind of almost playing,
playing it up.
I remember feeling that like,
like,
like it felt like we were doing bits almost or at least,
you know,
kind of,
yeah.
Well Norton is such a great performer.
We know we did it with him,
was the perfect guy to do it with in front of an audience cause he's just
immediately went into attack mode and it was just killing like right off the
bat.
And then,
um,
you know,
I think it's settled in after a while and it became intimate when I became
intimate also was when it was real obvious that everybody in the show in the
audience was a podcast fan.
And so that was fun for them to be able to sit in and watch it.
And even though we only did it once,
I wouldn't be adverse to doing it again.
And I also liked the idea that we could hand out the microphone and we hung out,
pass out microphones to the crowd and then the crowd would ask questions.
That was a fun thing that,
that little kind of a more relaxed question and answer cause I kind of stopped
doing that.
Uh,
rarely do that.
with an audience.
I think I did at one time last week.
And you're like,
oh,
you do the Q and.
A.
You know,
cause I haven't been really doing it because it leads to like a weird ending for
a show.
Like sometimes it's kind of like you're going up,
this is like a great finale of an ending.
And then it's like,
all right,
now let's go backwards and just kind of talk continental.
Yeah.
It's Kinda weird.
It's weird.
And then people would always ask me questions that weren't,
that really didn't lead themselves into being funny to me about Margaret Court
are know fighters.
Yeah.
It couldn't be,
there was a random fighter thing and then there was always like it.
Occasionally people would,
well not occasionally,
every time people would want to talk about drugs,
somebody would always yell a damn dude too,
you know,
fucking to me.
But mushrooms,
it's at a certain point in time you can only explain psychedelic experiences so
many times before you start becoming a character of your shelf.
You know,
you're like,
what am I,
how am I going to explain DMT?
The thousandth time?
I can't.
I'm going to give you some and you to smoke it.
And that's the only way it's going to work.
And I don't have any,
so good luck.
It's like go.
You know,
you can't,
people always say that a man like on Twitter,
please follow me and DMA.
I need to talk to you about DMT.
Guess what?
No you don't.
You don't need to talk
to me about some illegal drug.
I don't know you skippy.
You could be anybody.
It could be some fucking Weirdo.
You'd be a cop.
You can be crazy person.
You don't need to talk to me about DMT,
right when it comes to legal.
Yes,
it becomes league.
I'll talk to everybody.
I'll,
I'll hold a seminar on the fucking White House.
Front steps.
I'll tell people about it.
Yeah.
Tell you how to take three deep hits until that time.
I'm not saying shit.
That's the next war.
The war for consciousness.
The warfare control of he should be legal.
Um,
I think,
and I've said this many times before,
that we need schamens that if you're going to have something like mushrooms,
if you're going to have something like pay Payoti,
what you need is a,
a very,
uh,
rigorous,
sort of a ritual and a path to follow in order to have these experiences.
I don't think they should just be open for recreation.
I think too many people doom and fuck their head up and don't know what they're
doing and they can be so beneficial.
And I'm not saying that if you're a grown man,
you shouldn't.
Once you have experienced in these realms,
you shouldn't be able to get together with your friends and have a few mushrooms
and hang out and be silly and laugh.
I absolutely think you should be able to,
you should be able to,
like,
there's a lot of people that are like real serious about it and so you should
only do it for shamonic rituals and never do it or for recreation.
And I'm like,
why?
Why,
when it can be fun to do it for recreation.
They don't,
don't say you have to do it one way or another or that it's disrespectful.
Guess what?
The mushroom doesn't give a fuck about your respect in this world.
The,
the,
the mushroom is,
is a,
is whatever it is,
whatever that experience is,
it seems to be about forgiveness and love and fun.
You know,
that's what it seems to be about reality and truth and forgiveness and love and
fun.
And I don't think it minds if you use a casually,
but I think we need to have some sort of a setup where,
uh,
people are educated on it.
People like you don't just dive into it not knowing what the fuck it is.
You W we could easily have a service where,
you know,
if it was legal,
you could set up these shamonic places where someone could go and you,
this is Tom and Tom's going to guide you through the program.
Today's going to be the first day and today,
essentially what we're going to do is we're gonna sit down,
we're going to watch a documentary.
We're going to have a question to answer.
We're going to watch a documentary about the history of use of mushrooms in the
world.
And then you'll fucking see this documentary on Gordon Wasson and all these
other people that took mushrooms and what these tribes learned about it and how
this was suppressed by,
you know,
the various fucking dictators and kings.
And it'll go through the history of it.
And then the next day you go through the history of,
uh,
you know,
other psychedelic drugs and you know,
what's the benefit of them and what's the dangers of them and how does it
interact with your body and how can we find out if you know you're,
you're,
you know,
especially vulnerable,
and then slowly but surely you introduce someone into those,
those realms.
And I suggest starting them off really lightly.
I think that the first mushroom experience you should have,
it should be fairly high.
You should just just get a little bit of it.
So you just kind of get a feel of it and a little giggle and yourself system
where you don't feel scared,
you don't feel nervous,
you just go,
oh,
this is all right.
This is,
this is this crazy experience.
This is just weird.
Wow,
this is wild.
What a weird way of looking at the world I have now and then eventually slowly
but surely you should be introduced into the deeper and deeper dimensions into
the ideas that there is no real solid line between this world and the others.
It's just that this is all that we can detect.
This is all that we have the equipment to see and that what what mushrooms do,
any of these psychedelic drugs do is chemically alter the way your frequency or
the way your brain interacts with the universe and allows you to see some shit
that might just be there all the time.
He just might not have the ability to see it.
That's what I think.
I think all of it should be legal.
There's no way one person should be keeping you from these experiences.
What should be illegal and especially illegal to sell as anything that you think
to damage people or harm people or cause addiction and that shit already is
legal.
That shit has already been sold by pharmaceutical companies.
Things that are far,
far,
far more dangerous.
You know,
even when you come into like drugs that are dangerous,
like heroin,
you know what the fucking cure for heroin is or what they give you and you're
hooked on heroin.
They give you methadone,
man,
which in many people's eyes is way worse than heroin itself.
More addictive than heroin itself.
Hard to get off.
It's fucking dangerous shit.
It's all gross,
you know?
So I think that stuff that's bad for you as a society,
we should shun and that's what smart people would do.
That's what educated people would do.
What people that are in just this fucking whirlwind of momentum and hysteria,
that's not based on anything logical or rational or or realistic.
That's when the world is like that.
That's when you get drug laws like we have right now.
Nutty ones don't make any sense or not based on logic.
They're not based on knowledge.
They're based on some bullshit that was taught in the 1930s there based on some
sweeping drug addicts,
drug acts that which included things that weren't even psychoactive in humans in
1970 so that's what I think.
We're fucking being oppressed.
No question about it.
We have a system that's old as fuck and you're seeing it right now with his
craziest,
there's these demonstration and the occupy Wall Street movement.
That's the financial system.
That system is old as fuck.
We also have a legal system that's old as fuck.
It's stupid and that gets ridiculous and thinks that it's above the humans,
that it's supposed to be there to help and aid and assist and instead of
assisting the humans that it's that,
that you know,
it's supposed to be there to protect.
Instead they act as a fucking bully unit for big businesses that seek to push
things in one way or another in order to make more money.
W,
w the whole thing is just filled with clients across the board with the legal
system,
the financial system,
and the fact that things like marijuana and mushrooms,
things that probably aided in people's perception and the evolution of people's
perception since there were people from the very beginning.
I know for a fact that those things have helped me and I know for a fact they've
helped you and everybody that we know that's had psychedelic experiences has
been helped by them.
You know,
we know people that have had bad ones.
We know people that have bet scary ones,
but when you sit down with them and say,
what did you learn?
What did you get out of that?
They almost all say humility.
They almost all say a feeling of connectedness.
Member Ari.
Ari was like an angry dude for a while until Ari started tripping and when Ari
started tripping,
dude,
he started doing mushrooms like fairly regularly.
Every few months or so are you became a way nicer guy,
a way more aware of the fact that he should be a nice guy there.
Therefore,
you man,
this message brought to you by mushrooms and the marijuana shrunk to things that
are illegal to things early on.
This fucking wacky world.
We live in Brian Reichel.
We know it's not illegal podcasts pitches next week.
Joe Diaz on Monday,
supposedly David Tail on Tuesday.
I got to Holler at Homie and we got to work this out and we're going to try to
get Shane from uh,
vice TV,
which should be absolutely fucking spectacular.
And um,
Friday which is tomorrow night at the Ice House.
Gimme the lineup.
Uh,
we got Duncan Trussell,
our magical Steve run is easy.
Kevin Christie,
Sam Tripoli.
It's his birthday too and Jason Tebow and it's $15 on sale right now.
Last week sold out.
It's,
you can't,
I mean usually that,
that would be just one of those guys too.
Those guys are headliners.
That would be like a $30 show usually.
So
yeah,
that's a great shot.
It's a great show with a bunch of great guys.
And if you never seen Tripoli or nursing Dunkin or any of those guys that's top
notch,
stand up in La and it's only like 15 bucks,
15 bucks,
and they're going to be doing podcasts there.
So if you fucking get in on that,
they might let you go.
Hi Mom.
I'm going to say no,
no
that have people come in and we won't tell them where the studio is.
That's the thing.
Eventually the studio will have to be in glass,
so it'd be going to put,
put their boogers on it and shit,
but just get some really thick glass like plexiglass,
some bulletproof shit.
So we could do it right in front of people like the zoo.
Yeah,
that'd be awesome.
That'd be awesome to have it like right set up there were,
how about that,
you know that little door to the,
to the ice house when you go into that small room.
How about if that wall was just all plexiglass and you right where the ticket
booth is right next to it.
We had like microphone setup and we did it like,
so you could see right when you're on stage.
Yeah.
And we have the,
there's a little change machines where you usually get the zoo where you could
feed the animals,
but it'd be like skittles and stuff and they can give us candy.
Hmm.
Maybe they give you candy if you get laughs,
right.
Maybe if,
if you see a little,
yeah.
Like
it has to like the,
the decibel level of the laughter has to reach a certain level and then a green
light goes off in a little skittle and goes into a tray or joint or joint.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
Thank you to the fleshlight.
Once again,
we've been in business with those guys for a long time now.
It's been a very fun and uh,
it's funny.
It makes me take things less seriously because what are you looking for it?
I'm just finding it because,
um,
oh,
the blue one because I don't know,
man.
There's something ridiculous being sponsored by a rubber pussy and I think it's
good for us to be taken less seriously,
which is why you're here.
And,
uh,
anyway,
what I really,
Shane Smith contact me.
We're going to make this happen.
I'm so excited about that either next week or soon.
And um,
all right.
That's it.
You fucking freaks.
Thanks to the flashlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net,
click on the link.
Enter in the code name,
Rogan.
Get your 15% off.
Somebody says,
I shouldn't say enter in cause enter means to put in,
but fuck you.
How about that grammar people swat bag.
Uh,
I say that with all the love in the world.
Also,
we're sponsored by on it on it.com o n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain and also this new stuff called new mood.
It's five HTP and some other groovy shit that makes you feel better.
And also we have a shroom tech,
which is an athletic supplement for elite athletes based on the courthouse steps
mushroom that I have been using lately.
And I find fucking excellent.
It's all good shit.
You freaks.
Thanks for everything.
Thanks for making this podcast so successful.
Thanks for being cool as fuck.
Thanks for every time I go out of comedy clubs and theaters.
I hear from wait staff all the time that you guys are the coolest motherfuckers
they ever get to wait on.
Um,
I,
I this no bullshit.
We all here,
they were saying that at the meeting I had at the Ice House,
how you guys are your fans all drink and tip and that it's huge.
They're nice people.
You know,
I think you put that out there,
man.
You put that out there and people gravitate towards it.
And I think this podcast,
you know,
reinforces that and we need people to think,
to hear that you're supposed to think a certain way that it's,
it's a good way to think.
You know,
I heard that thing you did with Siri where you ask Siri that,
what is the meaning of life?
Did you see the Brody Stevens thing?
Yeah.
That was beautiful.
You know,
it's crazy in every told you a really good series said,
be nice to people.
Go for walks and what's good.
What was crazy is your fellow man,
Brody was just like,
right before that happened.
Brody goes,
Brian,
do you walk?
I'm like,
no.
And he goes,
you need to go on walks.
You need to read books.
He had a book.
He's like,
I'm reading the secrets.
I just make sure you read this.
And he's like,
don't eat fat foods.
Like he was giving me this whole lecture and I'm like,
let's see what series it has to say about the meaning of life.
And I played,
it was exactly what Brody said.
It gave me shivers like in the video,
like you can watch the video on Vimeo.
I have like goosebumps and we're all freaking the fuck out.
Maybe Brody Stevens now these on heavy meds is tapping into the true meaning of
the universe.
Maybe he's got the answers.
Do we need to have Brody Stevens on this podcast?
Yeah,
we need to go on his podcast.
How about that?
But that squad studious,
I will come to death squads,
studios in Pasadena and tomorrow night get your tickets because it will sell
out.
There's only 85 seats in this place.
Two shows,
eight and 10 30 is that what it does?
Uh,
eight and 10,
I think
eight and 10.
And we'll see you guys on Monday.
And as always,
we love you bitches,
you know,
we loved it.